Du sag mal, Kilian, hast du eigentlich die Kommentare gelesen, die uns die Leute zur letzten Folge geschrieben haben?
Du, Hendrik, wir haben keine Kommentare.
Doch, ja, guck mal schon. Dort.
Wo? Was?
Boah.
Ja, hi, Kilian.
Hey, Hendrik.
Wie geht's?
Cool. Und dir?
Ja, ja. Es ist Sonntag. Das Wochenende ist schon wieder fast vorbei.
Immer dieses Spoilern, wann wir aufnehmen.
Das muss ein Geheimnis bleiben.
Aber das letzte Mal haben wir es echt geschafft, die Folge schnell zu veröffentlichen.
Das ging viel zu schnell.
Das war ja fast Tagesaktuell, was wir da geschrieben haben.
Also wir hatten diesen Beitrag,
wir hatten dieses eine Thema,
was du während der Aufnahme auf Hacker News gelesen hast
oder von irgendjemandem geschickt bekommen hast,
mit diesem Atomwaffenangriff auf Hawaii.
Und ich glaube noch,
bevor es wirklich nach Deutschland drüber geschwappt war,
hatten wir die Folge auch schon draußen.
Krass, wir waren top aktuell.
Wir waren Tagesaktuell.
Okay, Wahnsinn. Ja, sehr schön. Wir haben ja jetzt auch ein bisschen aufgestockt. Wir sitzen jetzt tatsächlich mit Aufnahme-Academent da, das haben wir gar nicht gesagt.
Doch, klar. Ich meine, in der letzten Folge war das Thema Nummer eins.
Wir haben gesagt, dass wir die Quali anmachen, aber das wäre jetzt weiter tatsächlich mit Headsets und einem Aufnahmegerät, was zwei Spuren gleichzeitig unterschiedlich aufnehmen kann.
Das ist aber nicht wirklich thematisiert.
Das ist jetzt neu bei uns. Genau, das heißt, wir nähern uns mehr und mehr dem professionellen Podcasting an. Was wollen wir denn heute besprechen?
Ja, wir haben ein ganz wichtiges Thema, nämlich ist was extrem krasses im Internet passiert. Es gibt da so eine neue Webseite. Die ist wunderschön, oder? Vielleicht haben manche von euch das schon mitbekommen, diejenigen, die zufällig mal auf unsere Webseite gegangen sind und das vor langer Zeit mal getan haben.
Wir haben keine Webseite.
Aber jetzt schon.
Wir haben eine Webseite.
Wenn man jetzt auf akronomisier.bar geht,
ist da nicht einfach nur noch eine leere Seite,
beziehungsweise Weiterleitung auf den RSS-Feed
war da, glaube ich, vorher,
sondern da ist was Optisches so zum Anfassen.
Ich muss sagen, schön anzuschauen ist es trotzdem nicht.
Das entspricht exakt unserem Content.
Das ist einfach ein Selfie von uns beiden
als Hintergrundbild.
Wir haben uns jetzt entschlossen,
wenn wir eh schon ein kleines bisschen Geld dafür ausgeben,
dass wir unser Zeug auf Soundcloud
hosten. Das hat, glaube ich, fast 10 Euro
im Monat oder sowas gekostet.
Der Soundcloud haben wir jetzt seit fast einem Jahr lang
dieser sterbenden Firma Geld in den
Rachen geworfen, um sie leben zu halten.
Und ich hätte auch echt gerne gesehen, dass es dieser Firma
weiterhin, gut geht was,
ja, die deutsche
Internet-Startup-Firma, aber
irgendwie hört man immer nur so
Negativ-Nachrichten darüber und deswegen haben wir uns gedacht,
wenn wir eh schon Geld dafür ausgeben,
dann können wir uns auch einen
dedizierten Podcast-Hosting-Klient,
Dienstleister kriegen. Nachdem wir uns
ein bisschen verlaufen haben in den Möglichkeiten
des Selbsthostens und was
wir da Witziges aufziehen wollten,
haben wir letztendlich beschlossen,
wir würden so oder so Geld dafür ausgeben, wenn wir
die Folgen irgendwo hinlegen und den Webspace
dafür, was wir da jetzt technisch aufziehen,
was die Webseite generiert, statisch
und die irgendwo hostet, da hätten wir ein paar lustige
technische Lösungen für uns selber gebastelt.
Ich war echt kurz davor, selber irgendwie so einen Podcast
Service zu schreiben. Ja, ich meine,
die Möglichkeiten haben wir ja, aber
Wir haben gedacht, fuck it, wir zahlen Geld.
Wir wollen auch, dass es irgendwie was gibt.
Es ist auch besser für die Zuhörer, weil
auf die Art und Weise können wir uns mehr mit dem
tatsächlichen Inhalt auseinandersetzen.
Das geht mir bei vielen Projekten so. Man steckt lieber
Zeit und
Arbeit in die Entwicklung von dem
Drumherum und weniger in das Eigentliche.
Ich meine nicht, dass wir nicht viel Arbeit in unserem
eigentlichen Podcast stecken.
Das können wir so tun, als ob das so wäre.
Wir machen das ja alles bloß zum Spaß
und so ein Hobby kann
nicht schlimm, wenn so ein Hobby so ein kleines bisschen
Geld kostet. Und weil wir hier
keine großen Professionalitätsansprüche
haben, machen wir das Stück für Stück, langsam
eins nach dem anderen.
Letzte Woche haben wir uns, hätte es jetzt angeschafft,
diese Woche haben wir eine Webseite. Oh Gott, was kostet
nächste Woche? Da haben wir dann anständige Themen.
Never gonna happen.
Aber wir haben gerade tatsächlich mit der Webseite
ein sehr lange aufgehendes
Versprechen von uns endlich mal erfüllt.
Seit Folge 1 oder sogar 0
haben wir das versprochen, dass wir da was
hinpacken. Und es kam einfach nie.
Wir haben ja eigentlich, das muss ich sagen, ist ein bisschen schade,
wir haben ja eine wunderschöne Webseite
vom Lukas Vogel
designt bekommen. Die haben wir jetzt bislang
nicht benutzt, weil dieses Template, was man
hier auf Simplecast, wo wir
uns einen Podcast jetzt hosten,
einstellen kann, das ist relativ
simpel. Relativ
einfach. Vielleicht können wir da nochmal
Lukas bitten, da ein bisschen CSS drüber
zu wischen, aber
CSS-Lappen.
Naja, zum Beispiel hier,
Jupp hat gemeint, das Logo, da braucht
noch ein bisschen CSS-Schatten,
damit man den Text besser lesen kann, weil das Hintergrund
der Bild ja nicht wirklich als Hintergrundbild taugt.
Ja, da gibt es noch ein paar
Optimierungsmöglichkeiten, aber ihr habt es vielleicht
in eurem Feed-Podcatcher auch mit gesehen,
der Feed läuft jetzt schon seit ein paar Tagen auf die neue
Seite, da haben wir auch mal die Chance benutzt,
um ein bisschen die Show Notes aufzuräumen, zumindest
da, wo wir welche haben, und dass die alle
in einem einheitlichen Format sind, vorher war das so ein bisschen
gemischt, Plain Text, HTML und
Markdown, und tatsächlich können die meisten
Podcatcher ja nur HTML ab.
Wir mussten echt die Show Notes für fast jede Folge nochmal
komplett neu formatieren, das hat schon
Das war wieder mal so ein Abendmeta.
Ja, jetzt haben wir auch schöne URLs, die auf jede Folge zeigen.
Da ist auch ein Webplayer mit dabei.
Leider auf www.akronomisier.bar slash 00x oder wer auch immer Folgenummer ist,
findet man die wehrliche Seite.
Leider ist das www. an der Stelle Pflicht.
Das ist ein bisschen doof geregelt über eine Custom Domain bei Simplecast,
aber das haben wir dahingestellt.
Und was wir dann auch mit haben, leider über Disgusting Discuss,
aber zumindest haben wir etwas.
Wir haben Kommentare unter jeder Folge.
Oh, the shitstorm may begin.
Zumindest kann man uns jetzt direkt was dalassen.
Nicht so, wie es bisher zwei Leute, glaube ich,
gemacht haben auf Soundcloud.
Aber Soundcloud haben wir tatsächlich
als Backend, in Anführungsstrichen,
dann niemand wirklich groß gesehen gehabt.
Also der Mick hat uns ab und zu mal Kommentare
auf Soundcloud geschrieben,
aber ich habe das teilweise erst Wochen später
wirklich vorgenommen.
Es ist ja nicht so,
ob wir irgendwie eine Notification dafür bekommen hätten.
Also haben wir nicht.
Also am besten erreicht ihr uns immer noch auf Twitter.
Ja.
Ad acronymisierbar. Ist auch auf der Webseite
gerade so verlinkt, tatsächlich.
Follow on Twitter. Ist ein Link zu unserem Twitter-Handle.
Sehr schön, sehr schön.
Und daneben ist ein Feed-Link und ein
Listen-on-Apple-Podcast-Link und tatsächlich
auch ein E-Mail-Ass-Button,
der an uns beide geht. Echt? Ja.
Was ist denn für eine E-Mail-Adresse dahinter? Diese hier.
Acronymisierbar at fastmail.com
Der Vanalias, der an uns beide weiterleitet.
Ach ja, das ist gut zu wissen. Also schreibt uns E-Mail.
Nö, oder Twitter.
Erwartet nicht, dass ich innerhalb von
drei Wochen auf eine E-Mail antworte, weil ich das
mehr ganz hinterher komme.
Okay, so viel
zum Thema Hausmeisterei.
Ja, ne, schick,
Webseite.
Sehr schön. Was ist denn seit letzter
Woche noch so alles passiert? Es sind noch ein paar spannende
Attacken
veröffentlicht worden. Nach Spectre
und Meltdown
gab es jetzt
Skyfall und
Solace. Sind das nicht James-Bond-Filme?
Ja, Spectre ist ja auch
ein James-Bond-Film. Ach so, stimmt.
Krass. Ich habe eine Weile
überlegt, ob Meltdown
irgendeine James-Bond-Analogie
ist, aber nee, ist es nicht.
Und was ist da passiert? Es gab die
Seite
skyfallattack.com
Wenn ich das jetzt in die Show Notes packe, packe ich mal
die Seite aus dem Webarchiv da rein.
Weil die Seite
mittlerweile komplett blank ist.
Da siehst du nur noch, wenn du in den Code
reinguckst, steht da HTML
Body Body HTML. Cool.
Was ist eigentlich Skyfall?
Und Skyfall und Solace
sollten Attacken sein,
die auf andere Orten und Weisen
die Vulnerabilities, die
schon zu Spectre und Meltdown geführt haben,
ausnutzt. Und da hat jemand
eine Seite, wie gesagt, diese
skyfallattack.com-Seite gelauncht und gesagt,
hier, CVE so und so
und CVE so und so, sorgt dafür, dass
weitere Angriffe möglich sind,
weitere Details folgen. Und dann stand
diese Seite erstmal da und es hat sich so ein bisschen
verbreitet und einen Tag später stand
auf der Seite, nee,
das ist voll Bullshit, das habe ich mir bloß ausgedacht,
weil es mich irgendwie angenervt hat. Das war dann
irgendjemand, der hat dann auf dieser Seite,
das könnt ihr dann auch nachlesen,
detailliert geschrieben,
dass es schlecht findet, dass
ein paar Vulnerabilities
gehypt werden, indem man den catchy Namen gibt,
so wie wir beim letzten Mal gesagt hatten, ja eigentlich,
wir finden es geil, wenn sowas ein bisschen Publicity
bekommt, aber während
Meltdown und Spectre
durch die Presse gegangen sind,
sind nebenbei übrigens auch noch
Unmengen von anderen Vulnerabilities
gefunden und gepatcht worden, von denen
keiner was mitbekommen hat und
es ist eventuell etwas unverhältnismäßig.
Ja, aber im Zuge dessen
kann man auch sagen, dass Meltdown und Spectre wahrscheinlich
viel mehr Leute betroffen haben
und slash betreffen aktuell.
Und es ist schon ein bisschen
eine krassere Gewichtung auf jeden Fall,
die auf denen liegt.
Ich verändere meine Meinung
vom letzten Mal nicht. Die Sachen, die
die Vulnerabilities in den letzten ein, zwei Jahren rausgekommen sind
und die catchy Namen und Logos hatten,
waren auch alles wirklich große Sachen,
die einen Impact hatten.
Heartbleed hatte einen großen Impact.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Skyfor und Spectre.
Ach Quatsch.
Ich mache mal diese Skyfor-Seite zu.
Spectre und Meltdown haben dafür gesorgt,
dass jetzt ein Großteil der Cloud-Anbieter
schlechtere Performance bei gleich viel Stromverbrauch haben.
Und das ist so wichtig,
dass man solche Sachen schon public macht und dass die Leute darauf reagieren.
Das haben ja auch sehr viele, also wenn das nicht so public gewesen wäre,
hätten auch viele Admins wahrscheinlich nicht geguckt, ob sie ihre Kisten patchen müssen
oder ob sie betroffen sind und dementsprechend ist die Welt schon etwas sicherer geworden,
dadurch, dass man Werbung für solche Attacks macht.
Man kann auch viel besser mit anderen darüber konversieren, wenn man das bei einem Namen nennen kann.
Hier kennst du, was heißt denn du von CVI Nummer so und so? Welcher war das nochmal?
Im Prinzip ist es ja nicht falsch.
Er hat ja alles in der CVI-Nummer
oder irgendwo.
Aber ich finde den Namen, der ist schon catchy.
Da kann man schon was mit anfangen.
Ich habe auch eine Zeit lang überlegt, ob wir vielleicht mal in diese Sendung
jemanden einladen sollen, der sich damit auskennt.
So wie der Pentacast.
Genau.
Du nimmst mir das jetzt voraus.
Ich kenne ein paar Leute, die da ein bisschen näher dran
also die das ein bisschen
mehr betroffen hat.
Die DevOps-Leute bei mir in der Firma zum Beispiel
oder Freunde aus dem ASCII,
die jetzt bei Amazon arbeiten
und dort direkt
Kernelarbeit leisten und
Cloud-Dienste betreuen.
Aber uns ist jemand
vorausgekommen und zwar ist auch jemand
der Original-Finder
dieser Vulnerabilities
auch aus Dresden und wurde im
Penta-Radio interviewt
und die Folge verlinken wir hier bei uns
in den Shownotes.
Wo wir gerade von
Podcasts reden. Es kommen ja
jetzt schon relativ viele Podcasts aus Dresden.
ein bisschen Arbeit betrieben, um die Liste zusammenzutreiben.
Jetzt ist nicht viel Arbeit.
Man hat auf Twitter herumgefragt und alles, was uns eingefallen ist, aufgeschrieben.
Aber es sind nicht so wenige, wie ich gedacht hätte.
Na, was haben wir denn hier?
Also wir haben den Durchstarten-Podcast.
Die haben eine richtig schicke Webseite und beschäftigen sich damit,
wie man ein Startup gründet.
Okay.
Haben allerdings auch schon wieder aufgehört.
Es gab ein paar Folgen und seitdem ist es wieder monatelang nichts rausgekommen.
Aber ich habe es mir nicht angehört, aber ich glaube,
es müssten doch schon hörbar sein.
Okay, sehr bekannt. Das ist natürlich das Penta-Radio
beziehungsweise der Penta-Cast, wo nichts mehr irgendwie
kommt. Ich glaube, das ist das Übergang.
Da bin ich mit der Historie gar nicht so vertraut.
Aber das Penta-Radio ist ein sehr aktiv
genutztes Format. Genau, also das
sind alles Sachen, die vom Chaos Computer Club
Dresden gemacht werden.
Dazu könnt ihr euch einfach mal
auf C3D2 umschauen.
Es sind allgemein recht
aktuelle und technisch versierte
aktueller und technisch versierter
Beiträge
zu unterschiedlichen Sachen. Ich war auch schon mal zu Gast
Ein anderer, den wir uns als Vorbild genommen haben
so ein bisschen, ist die Mikrowelle.
Schönen Gruß.
Von Konsti hat ja noch den
Informantist-Podcast.
Das ist ein Interviewformat.
Aber die Mikrowelle ist generell ein cooler Podcast
von
U-Bahn-Verleih und Tomersch.
Zwei Dresdner, die
witzigen Kram machen, oft mit Geodaten, oft mit
OSM.
Der Informantist hat leider
bislang erst drei Folgen.
Konzi, mach mal was
Interview mal Leute
Wenn es sein muss, dann kommen wir vorbei
Um Gottes Willen
Das ist eine Drohung
Wenn du nicht keine neuen Folgen hochlädst
Dann kommen wir vorbei
Ich muss sagen, ich mache das extrem gerne
Die Datenspult-Folge hat mir extrem viel Spaß gemacht
Ich möchte in Zukunft
häufiger Gäste hier bei uns haben
Finde ich cool
Was ist denn als nächstes auf der Liste?
Wir haben noch den Multicast aus Dresden
einen sehr, sehr neuen Podcast von der AG DSN,
der AG Dresdner Studentennetze.
Die haben sowieso extrem viel Infrastruktur
und stellen extrem,
die sind ja quasi ein ISP insgesamt
und bieten auch Cloud-Dienste
für kleinere Studentenclubs oder sowas an.
Das ist ein ziemlich cooler Verein
und die haben jetzt einen Podcast, wo sie darüber
reden, was sie alles machen. Also hört euch den mal an.
Also die betreiben vor allem für die Dresdner Studenten
Wohnheime
die Infrastruktur, die Netzinfrastruktur,
dass man da auch als Bewohner
einen schnellen Internetzugang hat, der über das deutsche
schlussendlich nach draußen geht. Sehr cool
alles. Ich war sehr glücklich, die Jahre, die ich
im Wohnheim gewohnt habe, mein Zugang über die
AGDSN zu nutzen. Das war immer
top. In der ersten Folge, die ich gehört habe,
haben sie ganz kurz angesprochen, wie sie für
ein neues Wohnheim da das Internet reingelegt haben
und was das alles mit sich gebracht hat
und dann ist der Satz gefallen, nein, ich könnte dem mal
eine eigene Folge widmen.
Ich sage, ja, bitte.
Widme dem eine eigene
Folge. Ich möchte sowas
hören. Ich finde das sehr spannend.
Ein weiterer Podcast
den ich bloß mal ganz kurz angehört habe,
der aber offenbar auch aus Dresden kommt, ist die Couch-Fraktion.
Das ist ein Politik-Podcast.
Mehr weiß ich dazu nicht.
Ich werde auch nicht.
Also hört euch den mal an.
Einfach bloß, wir machen gerade Werbung für lokale Produkte.
Artisanally crafted.
Locally sourced.
Genau.
Achso, eine Sache, die auf unserer neuen Seite auch dazu gekommen ist,
ist, dass man jetzt, also das ist, wie gesagt,
das ist CMS, wo man sich Sachen zusammenklickt.
Man kann sich auch pro Folge aus einer festgelegten Liste an Sponsoren anklicken.
Und da wir diese Folge wieder im ASCII aufnehmen, werden wir für diese Folge wieder das ASCII als Sponsor anklicken.
Und Kolle-Mate, weil ich gerade eine trinke.
Also nur mal klar zu sagen, unsere Folge wurde bisher noch nie von irgendwas gesponsert, aber wir machen das immer mal zum Spaß.
Weil wir eh im ASCII sitzen, beide sehr ASCII-affin sind als ASCII-Mitglieder, weil es ja ein studentisch betriebenes Kaffee hier.
Und Kohle Mate trinken wir einfach sehr gerne und meistens werden wir aufnehmen.
Deswegen sind die ja Sponsor der ersten Stunde, wissen mittlerweile auch, dass sie Sponsoren sind, also ohne es zu tun.
Ich bin übrigens neulich immer wieder, ich habe ja immer Videomeetings mit Leuten von der US-Westküste.
Und jedes Mal, wenn das Meeting sich so ein bisschen hinzieht, dann mache ich mir dann doch nochmal eine Mate auf.
Dann hat mich neulich ein Ami-Kollege, der vor ein paar Monaten zum ersten Mal überhaupt in Deutschland oder überhaupt in Europa war, gefragt hat, trinkst du gerade eine Mate?
Ja.
Weil die das da drüben ja gar nicht haben.
Wurde ich jetzt gebeten, irgendwann mal welche vorbeizubringen.
Wo ist die Nummer in Santa Monica, Santa Clara irgendwo da?
Santa Barbara.
Santa Barbara, sorry.
Das stimmt gar nicht.
Gar nicht mal so weit davon kriegst du ein bisschen Club Mate für astronomische Preise.
Ja, das glaube ich.
Kannst du in San Francisco
tatsächlich erwerben.
Ich wüsste da gerne mal mehr drüber. Also ich bin
mich überrascht, dass es ehrlich gesagt, dass es sowas dort nicht gibt.
Weil die haben ja eine extrem geile
Craftbeerkultur, die
so cool ist, dass sie zu uns rübergeschwappt ist.
Und
die ganzen Hackerbrausen sind eher
scheinen so ein rein, nicht mal europäisches,
sondern wahrscheinlich so ein rein deutsches Ding
zu sein. Ist das eventuell so?
Ich glaube tatsächlich, dass es so ist. Ich würde mich gerne
was haben wir lernen lassen an der Stelle.
Schickt uns mal bitte. Ach, es gibt doch
Hackerbrause.de
oder so ähnlich. Da gibt es einen Blog,
der
relativ viel aufgezählt hat.
Hackerbrause.de, genau.
Das einzige
Wachblog.
Es gibt übrigens auch ein O'Reilly-Buch,
Hackerbrause. Ich weiß nicht, ob das echt ist.
Herrlich.
Und das ist ein
Blog über Hackerbrausen.
Ich glaube, der aktuellste
Beitrag ist, dass Berliner Mädchen
mit T. Mädchen.
Eine derlose Mate.
Wie würdest du das hier aussprechen?
Leo.
Leo Fuze Matte.
Natürlich am Ende.
Und Kreuzbär
und Koffeina
Cola und
Club Mate Granat.
Also das ist hier
Surftipp.
Hackerbrause.de. Ich glaube, die war noch mal
zu Gast in irgendeinem
CAE, als es um Mate ging.
Sehr empfehlenswert.
Das müsste eigentlich so die
Einkaufsempfehlung fürs ASCII sein.
Was haben wir denn mal noch nicht gehabt?
Gehen wir mal auf hackerbrowser.de.
Da gibt es eine lange Liste.
Wir sind ja doch recht beschränkt in unserem Marte-Angebot.
Wir haben ja glaube ich nur fünf oder sechs verschiedene Sorten.
Ja, stimmt. Das ist ganz schön schlecht.
Aber bevor wir es hier vergessen, machen wir die Liste
der Dresdner Podcasts.
Oh, was fehlt noch?
Da fehlt noch die Zukunftsmusik.
Oh, stimmt.
verlinken wir auch. Das sind zwei Physiker, die
darüber reden, was in der Zukunft so alles passiert.
Ich habe mir auch bloß mal ganz kurz angehört.
Klingt eigentlich ganz spannend.
Also ich muss sagen, mich interessiert
es hauptsächlich, weil das halt Leute aus der Region sind,
was
denen noch so über den Weg läuft,
was uns vielleicht entgeht.
Das einzige
der letzte Podcast, der mir noch so einfällt,
der mit aus Dresden kommt, der gibt bestimmt sogar noch mehr,
ist ein Drittel von Hallo Zwift,
der unseren Hörern mittlerweile
bekannt sein dürfte, wenn nicht
sogar unsere Hörer von dort kommen.
Also wir empfehlen uns gerne immer gegenseitig weiter.
Nee, cool. Es gibt echt ein paar
coole Podcasts aus dieser Stadt hier.
Gefällt mir.
Das wäre ein Aufruf an die Hörer.
Macht mehr Podcasts.
Setz dich einfach mal hin, so wie wir. Wir haben auch einfach gesagt,
hey, lass mal mit dem Handy zwischen uns
einfach mal aufnehmen.
Und dann war das plötzlich irgendwo hochgeladen.
Und dann haben das Leute angehört.
Das schockiert mich im Echelass ein bisschen.
Das ist ein witziges Gefühl, gerade wenn ich mir auf der
neuen Seite die Download-Zahlen angucke.
Wir haben noch gar nicht gesagt, hier abonniert
mal und wir haben schon
ein paar hundert Downloads. Das ist ein bisschen
gruselig. Wir haben einfach die Feed umgestellt
und das lief einfach. Das fand ich sehr, sehr angenehm.
Selbst so komische Clients wie
Overcast haben es einfach hingekriegt,
einen komplett anderen Feed oder derselben
URL einfach sich zu merken, welche
Folgen abgespielt waren, obwohl gerade
diese App damit nicht so gut zurechtkommt.
Wir haben eigentlich so viel geändert,
dass die Yu-Yu-IDs,
die normalerweise pro Item in so einem Feed
drin sind, komplett anders sein müssten.
Da sind IDs tatsächlich drin? Ich bin da mit RSS
nicht im Kopf vertraut.
Ich spreche kein fließend
RSS, um das zu wissen.
Ich dachte, du sprichst, aber du kannst
Lurum Ipsom auswendig.
Ach, genau.
Das Datum stimmt aber halt auch
nicht mehr. Das haben wir beim Mindset seiner Folge geändert.
Und die Titel sind auch alle anders. Ich weiß
nicht, woran Player das festmachen.
Vielleicht Hauptnach-Index, das ist die erste
Aua.
Hat euer Client vielleicht irgendwas heruntergeladen,
neu und fand ich dir komisch? Dann sagst du mal bescheiden,
das würde mich interessieren.
Ja, also ich muss sagen, es passiert mir manchmal bei einem,
bei meinem, ich habe ein Tiny Tiny
RSS laufen und es gibt
ein paar Blogs, da sehe ich
plötzlich, sehe ich ab und zu mal plötzlich
ganz viele neue Beiträge und dann gucke ich mir die an
und dann sehe ich, das sind
alle Beiträge, weil der irgendwas mal umgestellt
hat und mein Feedreader dann nicht damit
klarkam. Das ist dann immer sehr schade.
Aber bei meinem Client ist es auch nicht passiert.
Also gerade in der Podcast-Welt ist es ja eigentlich halbwegs normal,
dass viele Anbieter, viele Podcast-Hoppen,
wie würde Maintainer sagen, Podcast-Hosts,
ihren Podcast mal den RSS-Feed einfach durch einen anderen komischen Analytics-Service durchjagen
und dann quasi noch einen Redirect davor hängt.
Und da geht halt bei manchen Clients was kaputt.
Aber im Prinzip ändert sich ja nichts an den Source-Daten.
Und wir haben halt nur die Source-Daten ausgetauscht.
Und es ging einfach, das habe ich echt irritiert.
Und ja, wer weiß, vielleicht hören wir da noch einfach unsere eigene...
Achso, ihr habt das jetzt nicht gehört.
Wir haben einen kleinen Einsprecher gemacht,
den wir nur auf Soundcloud dann veröffentlichen als Folge 14 Platzhalter.
Für die Leute, die trotzdem noch diesen Feed abonniert haben,
als Hinweis, bitte abonniert doch mal neu.
Und wer weiß, vielleicht landet das jetzt einfach in meinem Catcher,
weil es ist doch nicht aktualisiert.
Das werden wir dann sehen.
Was haben wir an Themen für heute so?
Hast du gesehen, dass
Windows jetzt mit
Curl ausgeliefert wird?
Ich habe sowas gelesen. Das heißt,
dass jetzt Curl die Standard-ATTP-
Implementierung für alle Plattformen ist?
Oder wie?
Ich wüsste jetzt spontan keine Plattform, die
Curl nicht rumliegen hat. Also vielleicht keine Ahnung,
wie das mit Mobilgeräten ist.
Aber da ist es ja eh ein bisschen anders.
Kannst du mir mal kurz erzählen, was Curl ist?
Ja, ich weiß, was Curl ist.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das spontan definieren kann.
Kür macht ja quasi alles.
Curl ist ein Projekt von Daniel Stenberg.
Der ist, glaube ich, Schwede.
Der arbeitet mittlerweile für Mozilla.
Der hat sich irgendwann mal gedacht, ich bin beschreiben.
Mozilla?
Ja, ja.
Das ist ja witzig.
Der hat sich irgendwann vor ein paar Jahren mal gedacht,
ich baue mir mal ein kleines Tool, was HTTP spricht,
weil ich muss mir was runterladen können.
Und das Krasse ist aber, dass Curl sowohl HTTP als auch FTP,
als auch IMAP,
als auch POP, diverse
Sachen, die eine URL,
also durch eine URL ausdrückbar sind,
versteht.
Und sehr viele Anwendungen
einfach als HTTP-Stack
die Libcurl bei sich einbinden.
Also es gibt auch Bindings für fast alles
und relativ viele Sachen nehmen einfach
Libcurl mittlerweile. Das Projekt gibt es seit
fast 20 Jahren jetzt. Wusstest du, dass
Curl einen Flag hat? Also die
CLI von Curl hat einen Flag, die dir
für deinen Curl-Befehl, den du gerade ausführst,
direkt C-Code rausgeneriert,
der Libcurl linkt
und das kannst du dann einfach darauf aufbauen,
schnell was raus...
Also Curl ist ein Kommando-Zahlen-Tool
und eine Library.
Du kannst in das Kommando-Zahlen-Tool einfach reinhacken,
indem du mal C-Code und das kompiliert
dann zu einem Programm,
was einfach immer Libcurl linkt
und immer die gleiche Sache runterlädt.
Genau, das habe ich letztens auf Hackernis mal gesehen.
Du musst dafür bloß
deinen Curl-Befehl eingeben und hinten
minus minus libcurl und dann sagen, hier machen wir
diese C-Datei und dann outpostet ihr dir einfach
direkt diesen Befehl in
und dann sagst du, geht es jetzt hier diese C-Datei?
Genau, also du kompilierst dir direkt, hast du
eine Binary, die genau das tut, was du
vorher gemacht hast, die an libcurl ranlenkt
oder du baust dir halt darauf da was auf
oder fängst an, einen API-Client zu schreiben
und darauf bauen mit libcurl. Ja, super witzig.
Finde ich cool von libcurl, dass das geht.
Nee, aber Microsoft hat sich dafür entschieden,
curl direkt mit Windows auszuliefern.
Curl läuft ja schon länger, auch auf Windows,
seit Ewigkeiten, 95 steht hier
im Blog von Daniel
Steinberg aus Stemberg. Seit 95
gibt es, ich muss, ich rede mal
weiter, ich schaue mal gleichzeitig nach, seit wann es Köln
überhaupt schon gibt. Also du kannst
das schon immer bauen auf Windows-System
und Microsoft hatte da
ein bisschen Spaß gehabt und hat mal irgendwann, meine ich mal,
was
quasi Körger-Alias auf ein anderes
Ding, was in der PowerShell, ich glaube,
ich will gleich nochmal nachlesen,
was daran stimmt, weil ich gerade in Erinnerung habe,
aber aktuell wird mit aktuellen
Version von Windows tatsächlich
normales Curl mitgeliefert.
Initial Release 1997.
Krass. Okay, dann hast du es halt
bauen können auf Windows 95.
Achso, das heißt mit 95.
Ja, also das kam nicht
vor Windows 95 raus.
Genau, aber finde ich sehr cool.
Somit hast du Curl quasi auf jeder
bekannten Plattform zur Hand und kannst damit
bekannt loslegen. Du weißt, wie es funktioniert.
Man kann es benutzen.
Ja, ist schön.
Aber gerade bei so HTTP-Sachen finde ich es gut,
wenn es unterschiedliche Stack-Implementierungen gibt,
weil du sonst so Charakteristika oder kleine Quirks
dieser Library zum quasi Standard erhebst,
wenn sie jeder verwendet.
Die nutzt ja nicht jeder gleich.
Das ist ja noch das Witzige daran.
Die sind ja gerade von Microsoft
beziehungsweise von Apple
beziehungsweise von anderen Distros,
die maintainen das ja selber.
Somit hat die Microsoft-Variante von Curl
hier diverse Features auch nicht mit drin,
wie HTTP 2 oder keine Ahnung,
ein paar andere Sachen.
Ich habe auch eine leicht outdated Version direkt genommen.
Es ist nicht alt, aber nicht die aktuellste, meine ich jetzt.
Aber ich baue die Microsoft und maintain die von Microsoft
und nicht von Daniel Sternberg.
Eine andere Sache ist, witzigerweise,
Libcurl ist halt in C geschrieben.
Und der Daniel Sternberg hat echt mal bei sich vor kurzem,
das können wir vielleicht auch noch verlinken,
in Blogpost geschrieben,
brauchen wir jetzt neue, moderne, safe, sichere Programmiersprachen.
Und dann hat er mal so überschlagen,
die meisten Probleme,
die es bei Curl in den letzten
Jahren gab, das waren nicht wirklich
Speicherverletzungen oder so, das waren
dann eher so Logikprobleme, die aufgetreten sind.
Und das ging auch auf Hacker News hoch und er sagt,
naja, das brauchen wir nicht, wir können das Zeug auch weiterhin
in den C schreiben. Ich glaube, am gleichen Tag
sind noch zwei Vulnerabilities in Curl.
Die genau daher
gekommen sind, das waren irgendwelche
Challenge accepted.
irgendwelche Overflows oder sowas.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das im Nachgang
zu diesem Post war, das war dann fast zu knapp.
aber das war so ein bisschen, da hat er sich so ein bisschen aufs dünne Eis begeben mit seiner Aussagen.
Aber ja, dieser Wikipedia-Artikel liest sich eigentlich ganz witzig.
The Curl wird hier beschrieben als Anwendung, Type FTP Client, HTTP Client
und spricht aber laut der Zusammenfassung hier DICT,
FTP, FDPS,
Gopher, HTTP,
mittlerweile HTTP 2,
dann zählen sie aus irgendeinem Grund
Put, Post und HTTP Proxy auf,
es macht IMAP, Kerberos, LDAP,
POP3, RTSP,
SCP und SMTP.
Ja, aber cool,
Curl ist jetzt auf jeder Plattform drauf.
Krasses Ding, Curl hat die Weltherrschaft.
Ja, es gibt ja auch für jede Sprache
Bindings dazu, obwohl ich es echt schön finde,
dass die Leute auch mal hingehen und
HTTP neu implementieren.
Das gibt ja dann auch schon gewisse Vorteile dadurch.
Was ich bei mir immer mache ist,
auf meinem Dienstrechner ist kein W-Gate installiert
und ich bin auch immer zu faul, das zu installieren,
aber ich benutze es irgendwie doch schon noch sehr gerne,
weil es ein einfacheres Interface hat als Curl.
Bei Curl musst du halt nur ein Flag mitgeben.
Bei Curl musst du halt noch dieses große O mitgeben.
Aber das hat mich dann irgendwann mal genervt,
dass ich immer wieder WGET eingegeben habe und das gab es nicht.
Deswegen habe ich es einfach mal gelesen.
Schön.
Aber es gibt für solche Sachen,
gibt es ja auch mittlerweile andere Tools.
Es gibt RGET, es gibt glaube ich drei RGETs.
Ist das ein Rust Rewrite von WGET oder was?
Genau.
Wirklich? Okay.
Das hat mich irgendwann mal verlinkt gesehen irgendwo auf Reddit.
Dann habe ich mir das über Cargo installiert.
Und was es macht, ist, dass es die Datei runterlädt.
du kannst das ja über HTTP vorher fragen, wie groß ist die?
Und dann macht der
N Streams auf gleichzeitig
und lädt die
einzelnen Bestandteile davon parallel
runter. Also das erste Viertel, das zweite
Viertel, das dritte Viertel, das vierte Viertel gleichzeitig.
Und zum Schluss stitcht du das zusammen.
Und damit wollte ich mal was runterladen und hab das dann
gedacht,
das kann leider noch nicht
was brauchte ich
achso,
Zertifikatschecks verbieten
und dann
finde ich das auf GitHub,
klont das, patch das da rein,
so eine halbe Stunde lang,
dann baue ich es und wundere mich, warum das
komplett anders aussieht als das Ding, was ich
über Cargo installiert habe
und dann gucke ich nochmal nach.
Ah, das sind zwei unterschiedliche R-Gets.
Das ist natürlich naheliegend, wenn du
einen HTTP-Download-Client für die
Kommandozeile baust, dass du ihn irgendwas
Get nennst und wenn es ein Rust ist, dann natürlich R.
Also haben zwei Leute dieses Ding R-Get genannt.
Und auf dem Kongress habe ich einen gefunden, der hat
sein cooles Tool vorgestellt, das auch Arget hieß,
hab ich gesagt, ah, das ist cool, das hab ich schon mal gesehen.
Das kannst du ja gar nicht gesehen haben,
das hab ich noch gar nicht auf GitHub geschoben.
Dann solltest du dir vielleicht einen neuen Namen ausdenken.
Ja, anscheinend.
So ein paar Name-Collisions.
So wie der in Things Called Swift.
Das war schon mal ins Leben gerufen irgendwann.
Da ist doch neulich schon wieder was Neues dazu gekommen.
Es gibt so einen Malerdienst irgendwo in Osteuropa,
die sich Swift irgendwas nennen
und sogar das Swift-Logo auf ihre Autos klatschen.
Hm, das ist super dreist.
Cool.
Ja, also ganz ehrlich, da hat
Apple namstigen schon so ein bisschen
ins Klo gelangt.
Man nennt halt eine Neusprache blöderweise
eher nicht so wie eine bestehende Programmiersprache.
Ja, das gab es auch, genau.
Es gibt übrigens eine Programmiersprache, die heißt Curl.
Auch nicht schlecht.
Als ich es gerade auf Wikipedia gesehen habe,
gab es Curl mit
kleinem C und großem URL.
Das ist das Curl, von dem wir gerade die ganze Zeit reden.
Und dann gibt es Curl, die Programming Language.
Witzig.
Muss ich jetzt nicht drauf eingehen, ich sehe es auch gerade zum ersten Mal.
Können wir mal das Thema aufsparen für die Zukunft.
Schön sieht es nicht aus.
Achso, das scheint so eine Art
Markup-Sprache.
Mit Curly Braces.
Und Style
in den Text drin.
Ah Gott.
Gibt es auch seit 1998, deswegen sieht es aus wie
HTML3. Sehr gut.
Apropos Sachen,
die auf GitHub sind.
Ich hatte neulich einen kleinen Zwischenfall
auf Arbeit.
Ich benutze ja
VS Code und ich kann
Editoren nicht benutzen, wenn sie keine Wim-Motions
unterstützen. Deswegen habe ich mir den Wim-Mode installiert.
Aber plötzlich ging dieser Wim-Mode nicht mehr.
Und ich schalte dann hin und her
und mache den an und aus, diese Extension
und lade das Fenster
neu und es geht immer noch kaputt.
Bei VS Code ist ja auch bloß eine Elektronanwendung.
Du kriegst oben so eine kleine
Warnung eingeblendet und wenn du
irgendwie unter Hilfe
oder irgendwo im Untermenü kannst du dir diese
Chrome-Debugging-Tools dann anmachen
und dann diese Logs reingucken. Und da stand
halt eine krasse Fehlermeldung. Da dachte ich mir, hä, wieso
kommt das jetzt plötzlich?
Und dann gucke ich nach
auf GitHub. Ah,
da ist gerade eine Version rausgekommen
vor zehn Minuten.
Und gucke da rein.
Was hat die gemacht? Die fixt irgendwas. Aber das sieht
genauso aus wie das, was bei mir kaputt ist. Warum ist das
jetzt bei mir kaputt, wenn das
hier auf GitHub gefixt ist? Und dann lese ich ein bisschen in die
rein, dann war schon
auf diese Sache, die da kaputt gegangen ist,
ich muss die Seite nochmal kurz aufmachen,
war schon ein Thread mit irgendwie
50 Antworten entstanden, weil er hat gesagt,
oh, das ist kaputt, bei mir ist es kaputt und ah,
und dann hat der Typ, der das maintained,
innerhalb von 10 Minuten einen Patch gebaut
und es dann nochmal veröffentlicht.
Das ist allerdings
ein Symptom
dafür, dass wir gerade Software verwenden,
die live gepatcht wird von irgendwem, der
irgendwelche Extensions maintained.
Krass, wie schnell die Updates da propagieren.
Das ist ja beeindruckend.
Das sind gut 50 Antworten
und innerhalb von ein paar Minuten
hat der 83 Daumen hochgekriegt
für diesen
Bug-Report.
Wir benutzen quasi die ganze Zeit Software,
wo wir Extensions von Leuten drin haben,
die potenziell diesen ganzen Editor auch kaputt
machen könnten oder unbenutzbar machen könnten.
Wahrscheinlich sogar mehr als das.
Das kann man im Code of the System ausführen.
Du kriegst die ganze Zeit Updates darüber reingezogen
mit auf potenziell
nicht funktionierende
Versionen von deinen Extensions.
Das ist schon ein bisschen bedenklich eigentlich.
Aber it's fine.
This is fine.
Der Hund, der in dem brennenden Raum sitzt.
Everything is working fine.
Nee, das stimmt ziemlich viel kaputt
und angreifbar. Da gibt es immer wieder diverse Sachen.
Leute, die auf Twitter schreiben, wenn wir in GitHub
mal down sind, von wegen, ja, es könnte nicht mehr arbeiten.
Ich kann meinst du das Projekt nicht bauen. Oh, cool,
dass du so aufs Internet angewiesen bist.
Vor allem auf eine Seite,
einen zentralen Hub von Daten und wenn
dieser zentrale Hub kaputt ist oder
sagt nö oder was auch immer, dann geht nichts mehr.
Das ist eigentlich ein Scheißzustand.
Ja, aber das heißt doch, dass ihr das Konzept von
Distributed Verstattung nicht verstanden habt.
Das zum einen.
Ich hätte für sowas dann,
bei Firmen hast du dann, wo du
nicht auf GitHub bist, hast du dann trotzdem intern
so eine eigene Instanz von
GitHub Enterprise, GitLab, Bitbucket,
um es mal alle aufgezählt zu haben, dass ich keine Werbung
für einzelne Anbieter mache.
Und wenn die mal aus ist, was bei uns
jetzt neulich auch schon mal passiert ist,
für so ein paar Stunden,
mein Gott, dann arbeitest du halt bei dir nochmal weiter,
du bist ja eh auf einem Feature-Branch, den du nicht mit anderen
Leuten teilst, dann pushst du
den einfach ein bisschen später nochmal, oder wenn
alle unbedingt jetzt gleichzeitig merchen wollen,
auf Master-Merchen oder auf
gemeinsame Branches-Merchen, machst du bei
größeren Projekten eh nicht.
Das heißt, dann fällt da immer kurz
der CI-Plan aus, der
deinen Develop-Branch oder deinen Master-Branch regelmäßig
baut, aber
ob du nur auf deinen Feature-Branch
pushst, um
deine tägliche Arbeit von deinem Computer
runterzukriegen und wegzusichern,
oder ob es vielleicht noch irgendwo bei euch
irgendeinen
einzelnen Linux-Rechner gibt, wo du mit
SSH draufkommst, wo du dir einfach mal
selber innerhalb von drei Minuten mit
einem Bear-Clone
ein
alternatives Remote zu deinem
Git-Repository anlegst. Ist doch
völlig Wurst. Obwohl
Repository es gibt, habe ich
nördlich erst gehört, ist auch nicht allen so bewusst.
Weißt du, was ein Bär ist?
Das ist ein komplett leeres Repo.
Das ist ein Git-Repository, auf das du pushen kannst.
Quasi eins, was kein
Working Directory hat.
Du kannst ja einfach bei dir lokal
einen anderen Ordner als Remote einstellen.
Dann
brauchst du aber nicht erwarten, dass wenn du dorthin
pushst, dass dort die Dateien auch liegen.
Das kannst ja nicht zum Synchronisieren gehen, weil
dein Working Directory entspricht ja nicht
deinem aktuellen
deinem aktuellen Head oder deinem aktuellen
Masterstand.
Mein Working Directory entspricht meinem Head.
Mein Working Directory ist doch mein Head per Definition.
Das ist doch das, was
den Head ausmacht, dass der den Punkt widerspiegelt,
den ich gerade anschaue.
Du hast immer
es gibt
drei oder vier
unterschiedliche Punkte,
die den aktuellen Zustand deines Git Reporters
repräsentieren.
Du hast dein Working Directory,
du hast deine Staging Area
und dann hast du dein Head. Und dann hast du vielleicht
einen Tag, den du gerade ausgecheckt hast. Das sind unterschiedliche Sachen.
Also wenn du jetzt eine Datei veränderst,
dann ist die in deinem Working Directory verändert.
Wenn du die dann mit Git
addest und die quasi grün machst,
dann ist die gestaged. Dann kannst du,
wenn du dann nochmal an dieser Datei was veränderst und dann
Commit machst, dann hast du nur die Sachen,
die du vor dem Staging
gemacht hast, committet und nicht die Sachen,
die du danach hast, committet.
Ja, nee, das meine ich schon.
Ergo, wenn ich jetzt auf ein Repository pushe,
was ein Working Directory hat,
dann beschwert sich Git
du weißt, dass das jetzt einen komischen Effekt hat, weil die Dateien
nicht automatisch ausgecheckt sind, die du da
Ich glaube, ich verstehe, was für einen Unterschied du gerade meinst
zu beschreiben
Es geht explizit darum, wenn du halt irgendwas auscheckst
Natürlich kennt Git unterschiedliche Sachen
ob das jetzt der letzte Commit ist
oder ob das der aktuelle State in meinem Working Directory ist
oder ob das der gestagete Content ist dazu
Natürlich gibt es diese verschiedenen Orte oder Locations
wo Dinge rumliegen können.
Durch verschiedene Wahrheitsquellen, ja.
Aber zeigt mein Head
nicht immer trotzdem auf
quasi den State, wie ich ihn aktuell
so vorliegen habe?
Abseits davon, was passiert mir, wenn ich jetzt mal
irgendeinen alten Commit auschecke?
Wie heißt das? Detached Head oder so.
Also der Head zeigt immer
auf den Punkt,
den du gerade als letztes ausgecheckt hast,
ob du den nur verändert hast oder nicht.
Ja, du hast das gemeint.
Also wenn du sagst Checkout Master oder Checkout Feature Branch
schon so, dann zeigt dein Head auf den
obersten Commit davon.
Achso, aber halt nicht den Dirty Content,
der da zumitzeigen könnte. Okay, stimmt.
Die Unterscheidung muss man auf jeden Fall machen.
Dementsprechend kannst du auch mal eben
ein Commit weiter vorne auschecken,
dein Head quasi dorthin bewegen. Der Head ist ja quasi
einfach bloß ein Pointer in diesem Graf.
Das meinte ich eigentlich zu sagen, dass der Head für mich,
also quasi die Lens in die
History da rein ist. Genau, das ist was,
wo man erstmal seinen Kopf
rumwickeln muss, wenn man Git lernt.
was ich am Anfang
nicht verstanden habe, ist, was nun wirklich den Zustand
meines Repositories
darstellt. Weil bei
anderen Version-Control-Systemen,
zum Beispiel
bei CVS oder SVN ist es ja
was komplett anderes. Da gibt es eine zentrale Wahrheit,
die checkst du aus, da pushst du drauf
und das
verhält sich ganz anders. Bei
Perforce hast du irgendwelche Change-Sets,
die du vorher anlegst,
wo du vorher reinschreiben musst, was du darauf
machen willst und dann kannst du da
Änderungen rein
Ich muss sagen, ich habe das am Anfang
auf Arbeiten mal ganz kurz benutzen müssen,
aber ich habe mich immer sehr unsicher dabei
gefühlt, weil ich es, glaube ich, bis heute
nicht richtig verstanden habe. Ich habe mal kurz mit SVN
gearbeitet für drei Semester oder so
und sonst ausschließlich
Ahnung, also ich kann ja nicht viel zu sagen, leider.
Ja, das sind so Wissenslücken bei uns,
aber ich bin auch froh, dass ich eigentlich nie
in größeren Projekten arbeiten musste,
bislang die andere Version-Control-Systeme
ältere Version-Control-Systeme
verwenden. The Curial würde ich gerne mit Spaß haben.
Du hast was verpasst.
Das haben wir leider
nicht aufgezeichnet.
Einen sehr spannenden Vortrag beim letzten
Rust-slash-Mozilla-Community-Dresden-Meetup.
Da hat der Henrik,
der übrigens unseren Podcast hört,
momentan wahrscheinlich bei Folge 7 ist und mir jetzt geschrieben hat,
dass er sich bedankt hat, dass ich ihn mal erwähnt habe.
Hey.
Hey Henrik.
Henrik. Ja, hab ich gesagt.
Du bist Henrik. Er ist Henrik.
scheiße ich nicht sehr.
Ein D oder kein D?
Anyway, ich würde noch gerne mal dazu
interviewen, er hat darüber geredet, wie bei Mozilla
Source Code organisiert wird.
Und das kann ich nicht wirklich
wiedergeben, weil die Mercurial
benutzen und da alles anders
heißt als bei Git. Also es gibt
keine Branches, beziehungsweise es gibt Branches,
aber die verhalten sich komplett anders als bei Git,
weil die nämlich permanent sind und nie gelöscht werden
können. Was wir als
Branche in der Git-Welt empfinden, ist bei denen
ein Bookmark, auf dem du dann arbeitest.
Du musstest vorher bei
Buxilla so einen
Bug anlegen für alles, was du machst.
Da werden dann deine Änderungen dran attached.
Und Sachen, die du
live, die du neu hinzufügst,
die landen auf Mozilla
Central, glaube ich. Die werden
aber regelmäßig von dort
in andere Repos
rübergemerged,
wo dann
die Beta und
Developer Editionen ausgebaut werden.
Also es ist ein komplett anderes Modell,
als du das vielleicht von GitFlow kennst.
Und ich konnte auch nicht, also es war
witzig, weil die haben echt für alles andere Wörter verwendet,
als ich das gewohnt war.
Witzig.
Witzig. Spannend.
Müssen wir mal mit Henrik reden.
Um das zu besprechen, wie genau das ausschaut.
Mich interessiert.
Wie organisierst du eigentlich deine Git-Replätze?
Machst du Feature-Branches?
Die meisten Sachen, an denen ich bastle,
mache ich alleine.
Also unabhängig, sagen wir mal Sachen,
wo du nicht mit anderen Leuten
zusammenarbeitest. Dann versuche ich
Feature-Branches zu basteln für Dinge
und da Dinge nur in den Master zu bringen,
wenn sie fertig sind. Natürlich
sage ich, versuche ich, was auch nicht immer
der Fall ist. Und ich habe jetzt
für mich persönlich, also für mich als Nachteil, ich hätte es gerne
mal gehabt, dass ich mal in einem größeren Kontext
was gebaut hätte, vielleicht in Zukunft,
aber noch nie mit
sehr vielen Leuten zusammen. Da kann man das auch alles
überblicken, da geht nicht viel kaputt,
da ist es auch nicht schlimm, wenn man irgendwie mal ein bisschen zusammenmergt,
das ist okay, man kann überblicken, wie die History ausschaut
und auf welchem Stand man aktuell ist, aber sobald da jetzt, keine Ahnung,
so 10, 15 bis 200 Leute an einem Projekt sitzen und es überhaupt nicht mehr geht,
da würde ich das gerne mal sehen, wie das, also da habe ich persönlich noch nicht die Erfahrung gemacht,
wie das dann gemanagt wird.
Es gibt ja schöne Schemata, mit denen du deine Commit-Messages zum Beispiel standardisiert
schreibst, beziehungsweise, ja, so bei größeren Repos bietet sich
es auch wirklich an, dass man
da ein bestimmtes Schema anlegt.
Kennst du zum Beispiel Semantic Release?
Nee. Das ist ein Schema,
ich habe es gerade mal in die Shownotes geschmissen, und zwar
kannst du ja
bei Git
Hooks
einstellen, also Skripte, die ausgeführt
werden, wenn bestimmte Aktionen eintreten, wenn du was
pullst, pushst, wenn du ein Commit machst und so weiter und so fort.
Und da kannst du zum Beispiel auch
das haben wir auf der Arbeit
bei einem relativ großen Repo, wo
viele Leute arbeiten, da ist
einen Hook dran, der deine Commit Message
evaluiert. Okay.
Und die muss ein bestimmtes Schema
einhalten und zwar
fängt die immer mit einem Tag
an, mit einem Keyword, also das heißt dann
Fix oder Feed oder
Chore oder Perf.
Das habe ich schon gesehen, ja.
Und dann in Klammern wie so ein Funktionsparameter
ein Namespace
oder
so eine Art
Namespace-Beschreibung, also sowas wie
unter Projekt A, unter Projekt B oder sowas.
Und dann in Klammern danach,
wie so ein Funktionsparameter,
so eine Scope-Beschreibung,
das sagt dann, wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel viele Projekte
in einem Repository hast, welches ist unter Projekt
und davon vielleicht sogar,
ob das Tests betrifft oder nicht, oder ob das,
keine Ahnung. Und dann schreibst du
Doppelpunkt und dann deine eigentliche Commit-Message.
Und das erlaubt es,
dass du die
parsen und daraus
sogar Changelogs einfach generieren kannst,
indem du einfach nur zum Beispiel alle neuen Features
seit einem bestimmten Tag daraus parsen
und daraus was generierst.
Das musst du natürlich auch dementsprechend
gut einhalten. Also ich glaube,
was dieser Scope, was in den Klammern
steht, das wird nicht so genau
überprüft, aber da musst du dann einfach ein bisschen
Konvention einhalten. Und das nächste
Schönere ist auch, dass man encouraged, dass die Leute
in die Commit-Messages noch mehr Details
reinschreiben. Das ist immer gut, ja.
Die erste Zeile ist ja
immer die Headline bei einem Commit, dann lässt du
eine Zeile frei und das beschreibt dann hier,
dass die Commit-Message dann im Idealfall
noch einen Body und unterschiedliche Unterpunkte
haben, wo
du dann auch beschreibst,
ob da Breaking Changes drin sind,
was für Tests du da angefasst
hast und so weiter und so fort und richtig Messages für
den Reviewer als nächstes, weil wenn ich dann bei mir im
Rebo einen Pull-Request aufmache, ist die
Nachricht ja nicht nur die erste Zeile, sondern auch
alles unten drunter, genau das, was
in deinem Pull-Request dann
als Kommentar drinsteht und
wichtig ist, dass man an der Stelle sich
dann auch in den Reviewer schon mal
jetzt während man die Commit Message schreibt,
nicht einfach nur für sich so als Log, was habe ich gerade gemacht,
sondern die Commit Message
sollte schon ausdrücken, sollte
schon eine Nachricht an denjenigen sein,
der deinen Code reviewen soll als nächstes.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Da halte ich mich auch dran.
Also solche Message sind unbedingt von
Change Some Stuff, das ist ja total nutzlos,
kannst du es auch einfach lassen.
Aber da irgendwie ein bisschen was Sinnvolleres reinschreiben und vielleicht auch
ein bisschen einen erklärenden Text, warum diese
Änderung gemacht wurde, ist für die Zukunft
echt hilfreich, wenn man da nochmal durchsteigen möchte.
Ja, und hier ist es jetzt tatsächlich so, wenn ich eine
mit Nachricht schreibe und mich nicht an dieses Format halte
und dann
speichere und den Editor schließe, dann
ist der Commit einfach noch nicht gemacht.
Dann gibt der
einen Wert ungleich
0 zurück und
der Commit hat nicht stattgefunden. Was du machen
kannst, ist, um dem zu entgehen,
du kannst die erste Zeile von deinem
Commit mit WIP in Großbuchstaben
anfangen, dass es Work in Progress ist,
weil du auch häufig was hochpushen musst, um
das irgendwie in der CI laufen zu lassen.
Das solltest du dann allerdings alles
wegsquaschen, wenn du
dein PR machst.
Übrigens, was benutzt du?
Benutzt du exzessives
Rebasing?
Wenig. Also hin und wieder mal,
aber ansonsten nicht.
Deswegen bin ich nicht der große Fan von
meine History ständig zu rewriten,
sondern ich bin auch nicht jemand, der
unglaublich, also manche Leute legen ja
unglaublich viel Wert, fast so ein bisschen unnatürlich
viel Wert drauf, dass die History schick ist.
Das ist für mich einfach so ein Non-Goal.
Die Codebase sollte schick sein
und die Git-History sollte bestenfalls ein bisschen überschaubar sein,
was das dann passiert, vielleicht irgendwo welche Branches,
wie heißen die Branches, die da zusammengemerged wurden
und dass man zumindest an den Nachrichten sich irgendwo durchhangeln kann.
Aber ich will nicht, dass ich eine Git-Merge-Commit-freie,
schöne, saubere, wunderschöne History habe.
Da gibt es nämlich bei uns auch zwei Schulen.
Es gibt ein großes Repo, wo viele Projekte drin sind von den Leuten
aus dem Standort in den USA und es gibt ein großes Repo von uns
und die sind an unterschiedlichen Stellen strikt.
Wo wir gerade beim Backchatten sind,
wollen wir mal wieder über Programmiersprache reden?
Ja, das lassen wir wieder.
Es gibt wieder was Neues,
ach nee, warte, es gibt jetzt was
Cooles weniger.
Vor ein paar Tagen stand auf Hacker News
die Programmiersprache
Eve,
die Entwicklung wird eingestellt.
Das habe ich gesehen, aber ich weiß nicht mehr, was Eve wirklich war.
Eve war so eine coole
und das ist
wie häufig, wenn du so ein Postmortem
von irgendeinem gestorbenen Künstler
oder sowas hörst, wird erstmal
in den Nachrichten oder so richtig
gezeigt, was der oder die
in ihrem Leben so gemacht hat und dann denkst du dir so,
ach, bis gerade eben hat es mich nicht interessiert, aber jetzt
wurde es erzählt, was der ist.
Stimmt, kenne ich und fand ich eigentlich
spannend und ich habe mir das nochmal angeguckt. EVE ist so eine
grafische Programmiersprache,
wo du Sachen zusammen klickst
und dann Aktionen miteinander
verknüpferst. Die hat dann auch noch eine
eine textuelle Darstellung, aber eigentlich war das
eine grafische Programmiersprache.
War es explizit zum Lernen gedacht?
Oder tatsächlich für
sinnvollere,
größere Sachen?
Nee, aber ich glaube nicht, dass die
explizit zum Lernen gedacht war.
Könnt ihr euch mal die Seite angucken.
Es gibt es noch.
WithEve.com
bzw. der Blog ist auf
incidentalcomplexity.com
Sieht eigentlich schick aus.
haben ja auch so ein paar Animationen, was sie sich
alles vorgestellt haben. Also war quasi
Editor und Entwicklungsumgebung
in einem Paket. Und Programmiersprache in einem.
Also es ist ja zwar ansläufig, wenn du eine
grafische Programmiersprache hast. Brauchst du den Editor, klar.
Aber ich weiß halt nicht.
Ich hätte mir gerne mal angeschaut.
Ja, jetzt ist es tot.
Also ich meine, der Tod,
der Code hört ja nicht von alleine auf,
plötzlich zu funktionieren.
Das ist so ein bisschen, es sieht doch so ein bisschen,
ich kenne mich damit nicht ganz aus, wie die
Interfaces, mit denen sie in Computerspiel-
Editoren zwischen Spiele-Engines die Aktionen
zusammenklicken. Da sieht man auch solche
grafischen Bäume, wenn dieser Trigger ausgelöst wird,
dann soll das und das passieren.
Ich gehe mich an so alte Quartz-Mac-Software,
wo du so schön verschiedene,
also das war ja quasi so ein bisschen reactive,
Dinge ineinander verhängst und dann
so Leihend ziehst von einem Output zu einem anderen
Input und da dir so ein richtiges
großes Board an Dingen zusammen
klasterst, was dann irgendwas tut
durchfließen, auf welche Art und Weise auch immer.
Schon eine echt coole
Standard-UI.
Irgendwas wollte ich dann letztens auf so ähnliche
Art und Weise bauen. Das hat mich kurz inspiriert
gehabt. Ich vermute, es war irgendwas aus dem
Studium, also irgendwie ET-Krams, aber
weiß gerade nicht mehr, was genau das war.
Ja, zumindest
ist es jetzt vorbei mit EVE,
der Programmiersprache.
Tja, passiert. Projekte sterben.
Ist immer schade, aber passiert.
Ein anderes Update an einer anderen Programmiersprache,
die wir auch schon mal erwähnt haben, die Programmiersprache
SIG. Ah, ich erinnere mich.
Es ist nochmal ganz kurz auf Herkern-News gewesen
mit der Überschrift, unsaved SIG
is safer than unsaved rust.
Aha.
Zugegebenermaßen
etwas obskures Code-Beispiel zeigt,
you'll find it in the
show notes, unsaved rust,
was dann tatsächlich zu
undefined behavior führt.
Ja, aber ich dachte, dafür sind unsaved-Blöcke da,
dass du halt scheiße machst.
Also nicht um undefined behavior zu erzeugen,
aber um Dinge zu machen,
die halt unsafe sind und die können
halt, du musst halt darauf achten, dass es halt
keinen Scheiß macht, das ist halt deine Aufgabe
und nicht mehr die des Compilers. Ich glaube, die
Quintessenz war, dass man dem, was man hier schreibt,
nicht unbedingt ansieht, dass man das,
dass man dieses undefined
Behaviour triggert. Wenn du natürlich auf Adressen
zugreifst, die potenziell nicht da sind oder auf
irgendwelche Typen
umcastest und dem Compiler sagst, trust me,
I know what I'm doing, das ist was anderes,
aber wenn du denkst, du machst das und es passiert
aber was anderes, ist ja das, was in
10-Bus die ganze Zeit passiert, dann
dann ist das schon eher
not desirable und das auch nicht in
Unsafe Rust, aber
in der Diskussion ging es dann ein bisschen weiter mit
ja, das ist schon
ein bisschen ein seltsames Beispiel und so und so
würde man das ja eh nicht machen.
Ich finde es schön, dass sich die einzelnen
Programmiersprachen, selbst
solche, nennen wir es mal vorsichtig,
kleineren Nischenprogrammiersprachen
wie SIG,
oder Rust,
da auf eine gewisse Art und Weise wissenschaftlich
vorgehen und sich jetzt
miteinander vergleichen.
Das ist auch richtig so. Also ich denke mal, dass das dazu führen kann,
dass dann halt
solche Sachen dann in den anderen Sprachen auch ausgemerzt
werden. Das ist eigentlich ganz schön.
Durch solche Vergleiche kann man halt auch wachsen und sehen,
was funktioniert und was nicht.
Das ist schon richtig.
Genau.
Ja. Apropos Rust.
Ich habe gesehen, du hast in letzter Zeit irgendwie so
zwei neue Libraries rausgehauen,
irgendwas mit JavaScript-Tooling zu tun haben?
Was war das denn?
Das spiele ich eigentlich nur rum bislang.
Ich habe da noch keine wirklichen Lips veröffentlicht.
Ich habe ein bisschen...
Ich habe ja eine große JavaScript-Codebase
auf Arbeit unter den Fingern.
Dann habe ich einfach mal ein bisschen Tooling drumherum
in Rust gebaut in meiner Freizeit,
um da Analysen drauf zu machen.
Zum Beispiel renn mal über alles drüber,
mach mal alle Package-Jasons auf
und schauen mal, was wir für vielleicht
unterschiedliche, konfliktende Versionen
von Dependencies
in unserem Code drin haben.
Nur um zum Beispiel die Download-Zeit
so ein bisschen zu optimieren
und allgemein die Codebase zu konsolidieren,
weil du möchtest ja nicht
drei unterschiedliche Major-Versionen
von irgendeinem Testing-Framework
oder so, was wir bei dir drin haben.
Drei unterschiedliche Major-Versionen
von einem Paket, von ein Library,
ist halt schon sehr witzig in der SimCodebase.
Ja, und dann, ich bin mir relativ sicher,
sowas gibt es auch in JavaScript, aber ich will natürlich
ein bisschen Spaß haben in meiner Freizeit, deswegen mache ich kein
JavaScript, sondern baue ich das
dann in Rust und
eine Darstellung, die
PackageJasonsParse
hatte ich ja als kleine Demo für Seade
schon mal gebaut und jetzt kannst du,
jetzt habe ich eine kleine Lib gebaut, ich habe die noch nicht auf
Creates.io veröffentlicht,
mit der du
einfach sagen kannst, öffne mir mal diese PackageJson
aus der Datei und was er dann macht, ist, dass er die
einzelnen Fälle, also dass er es nicht als
dynamisches JSON-Objekt liest, sondern tatsächlich
einzelnen Felder schon
semantisch passt. Das heißt, du hast
dann das URL-Feld, das ist tatsächlich ein URL-Objekt
und das Versions-Objekt,
was wirklich ein Semware-Typ
ist und auf die Art und Weise möchte ich dann
irgendwie noch ein bisschen Analyse vielleicht erzeugen,
um sagen zu können, guck mal, du hast hier konfliktende
Versionen oder sowas.
Ich habe auch jetzt mal angefangen, ein bisschen in den Cargo-Code
reinzuschauen, was die so machen.
Ja, und die
letzte Nacht habe ich mir damit um die Ohren geschlagen,
dass Jan, dieser alternative
NPM-Packetmanager
für sein
Log-File-Format
sich die Frechheit rausgenommen hat,
sich ein eigenes Dateiformat auszudenken.
Was? Das ist nicht ganz normal irgendwas
lesbares? Also Textbasis ist schon,
aber nicht irgendwas Bekanntes?
Es sieht grob aus wie YAML,
aber es ist nicht.
Okay, sehr witzig.
Es ist ein indentation-basiertes Format
und manche Zeilen hören
mit Doppelpunkt auf und andere nicht.
Und dann hast du so Key-Value-Paare, die mal mit Komma getrennt sind und mal nicht.
Was machen die das denn?
Und manche Sachen musst du aus dem String raus parsen und manche sind durch...
Also es ist bescheuert.
Also das hat npm5, die ja auch Log-Files eingeführt haben, wirklich schöner gemacht.
Die haben einfach eine Package-Log.json und ich glaube relativ viele andere Package-Manager.
Cargo zumindest hat eine Log-Tommel, also hat eine Cargo.log, aber es ist eine Tommel-Datei.
Okay, Swift hat Package-Resolve, was JSON ist.
Ja, also...
Das ist lesbar, verständlich.
Sich im Jahr 2017 noch neue
eigene Dateiserealisierungsformate
ausdenken, ist schon besuchbar.
Bestens wäre es ja, wenn die Logdatei irgendwie Protobuf
gibt.
Meinetwegen wäre mir auch groß...
Das ist Quatsch, warum?
Nee, wäre tatsächlich...
Es ist ja ein Format, was du eigentlich auch überhaupt
nicht mal eben selbst textuell erinnern
sollst. Und wenn es irgendwie ein
ASCII-basiertes Format ist,
wie JSON oder selbst das, was
sich Jahren hier ausgedacht hat,
lädt es ja schon dazu ein,
dass du nochmal reinguckst, ein bisschen rumliest und vielleicht ein bisschen was
anpasst. Aber selbst wenn, dann ist es halt so,
wenn du das machen willst, dann hast du sicherlich auch meistens
einen Grund dazu, das zu tun. Und das ist ja jetzt ein
komisches Gefühl von Security by Obscurity, wenn du
anfängst, das binär Daten zu speichern. Nur damit
keiner diese Datei anfasst. Ich kann es auch gleich verschlüsseln.
Nee, du möchtest ja auch dann in einem
Git-Div sehen können, was sich an dieser Datei verändert hat, wenn du sie neu eincheckst.
Die hat ja wirklich eine
sehr gute Daseinsberechtigung,
die so existieren sollte.
Und wenn ich da drinnen rumdoktern möchte,
dann möchte ich das auch können.
Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Aber das Schöne eigentlich an sowas wie,
ich weiß nicht, macht dir Protobuff das möglich?
Nee, bei Protobuff nicht.
Aber durch die Sachen wie Serde
hast du eigentlich eine relativ gute Möglichkeit,
das konkrete Serialisierungsformat wegzuabstrahieren.
Also ich habe was gebaut,
das lässt sich jetzt,
ich habe die gesamten Package-JSON-Properties
als im Rast-Typ-System
dargestellt und kann
jetzt quasi einfach mit
Serda-Json das
populieren und könnte das
jetzt mit irgendeinem anderen
Serda-Serializer in irgendein anderes Format
einfach ausgeben. In
Protobuf, in Messagepack, in
YAML, in Tommel, in
irgendwelche
binären Formate noch.
Was ich eigentlich ziemlich cool finde, aber auf die Art und Weise kannst
du, wenn du mal irgendwo für
größere Sachen Platz sparen möchtest,
das schon ganz gut wegoptimieren.
Das wäre ja cool, wenn dein
jetzt vielleicht nicht für die Logfiles,
aber wenn irgendein Tool was das kann.
Ich habe das für dieses kleine ASCII-Tool mal überlegt.
Da kannst du ja Dateien
in YAML handschreiben,
aber wenn es irgendwann zu viele wären oder sowas,
könnte man ja überlegen, dass man sagt,
wenn du es ja trotzdem noch alle parsen möchtest,
dann können wir ja die alten, die du nicht mehr anfasst,
da nochmal umcodieren in ein Format,
was sich schneller parseln lässt, wenn du es eh nicht nochmal
editieren möchtest. Das ist eigentlich ziemlich cool.
Und wenn du so ein großes Monorepo hast,
wo du viele Unterprojekte und Unterunterprojekte drin hast
und das mit Jahren verwaltest,
da kannst du ja auch so ein Workspace anlegen,
wo es behandelt, als wäre es ein Projekt
mit einer Liste Abhängigkeiten.
Und dann hast du eine Logdatei,
die ist schon 15.000 Zeilen lang.
Also das ist durchaus möglich.
Diese JavaScript-Welt, schon besonders.
Mal ganz kurz zurück zu Serde.
kannst du da auch, ich hab's gerade, wenn du
davon sprichst, die Konformate
ineinander her zu konvertieren
gibt's da schon irgendwas, was
das sehr generisch, ohne genaue Spektifikationen
wie die Daten ausschaut, so Pandoc-mäßig
hey, ich hab eine JSON-Datei, hau mir das mal
als YAML raus, oder hau mir das mal zu dem
oder von dem, dem so ganz
generisch bleiben. Ja, ja, sowas hab ich auch schon mal
gebaut, das hieß
YAT, also bei mir auf GitHub, JSON
all the things, das nimmt
Tommel, YAML
rein und macht auf jeden Fall JSON draus.
Aber läuft das serdebasiert?
Das geht serdebasiert. Also du hast ja immer...
Ja, dann kannst du ja ganz generisch aufgrund des eigenen Ausgabeformats
noch machen. Ja, aber du möchtest vielleicht noch validieren,
dass da bestimmte Sachen drin korrekt sind. Also dass du,
wenn du da
Versionen angegeben hast, dass das ein valider
Semware-Ausdruck ist oder sowas. Natürlich brauchst
du es, wenn du es einfach bloß umcodiert hast, musst du es nicht genau
wissen, aber wenn du es benutzen willst, dann
ist es schon sinnvoll. Also ich hab, das hatte ich
bei dem Beispiel letztes Mal
über diese Wikipedia-Library.
akronomisierbar
Folge 13, ganz
zum Schluss, und da
hat er das, hat er auch sehr alle benutzt, um
diese JSON-Rückgaben
von Wikipedia
anzugucken, aber was der halt nicht gemacht hat,
ist, dass er es nicht auf den konkreten Rust-Typen
gemappt hat, sondern dass er einfach,
also du kannst entweder das machen, oder du kannst dir einen
generischen JSON-Value-Typen
zurückgeben, und das ist dann so eine
Composite-Datenstruktur, wo du
ein Objekt hast, wo unten drunter
vielleicht Arrays oder vielleicht Strings oder
sowas sind. Und da musst du dann
strukturell drüber gehen und sagen, das hat er
auch da gemacht, ne? Gib mir das mal als Objekt.
Du kannst ja alles,
das ist ja prinzipiell alles, jeder
Serde
JSON-Value-Typ ist potenziell
ein Objekt oder eine Zahl oder ein String oder
ein Array. Deswegen sagt er, dann gib mir das als
Objekt und dann kriegst du entweder Sum oder
None zurück, weil das könnte ja potenziell nicht
dieses Format haben.
Und dann gib mir mal daraus
alle Sachen, alle
Properties und dann gib mir mal daraus
das, wo dieser Key drin steht
und dann gib mir mal daraus bitte
das dritte Element oder sowas. So steht
es dann im Code drin, anstatt von
parse mir mal
dieses JSON in meinen Typen rein
und dann greife ich mal direkt auf diesen Typen zu.
Da hast du auch sinnvollere
Parsing-Fehler. Wenn das Format jetzt nicht
eingehalten wird, dann siehst du bei
Zerde schon ziemlich schön.
Gerade dadurch, dass ich
angegeben habe, dass
in das URL-Feld kommt
kein String rein, sondern eine URL,
dann sehe ich beim Parsen
da in Zeile 52, wo URL
steht, ist keine valide URL drin.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich cool.
Das erinnert mich so ein bisschen an, wie die Swift-Welt das gemacht hat,
vor Swift 4, wo Codable kam,
was ja quasi so ein bisschen das tut, was
Serle macht. So Encodable und Decodable,
aber abstrahiert weg von dem genauen Format.
Ob das jetzt JSON ist oder
Property List, was halt von Codable mitgeliefert wird,
aber theoretisch auch alles andere.
Vorher hast du halt auch
meistens irgendwelche Object-Mapper benutzt,
die irgendein Dictionary,
das JSON-Everdictionary
lesen und dann da durchgehen und so, ja,
und dann gehe ich in diesen Key rein, jetzt caste ich mir das zurecht,
was ist wahrscheinlich das hier und das ist jetzt
mein String und irgendwie soll ich in eine URL, dann mache ich jetzt
den String zu einer URL und dann kommt das da rein
und da ist nochmal ein Sub-Array,
das wird jetzt das Objekt zu einem Eric.
Du musst halt sehr viel hinschreiben.
Und das läuft jetzt auch alles ein bisschen schicker.
Aber worauf ich gerade noch hinaus wollte,
wir bänden jetzt ja
sehr viel an JSON an sich,
aber andere Formate haben doch
mehr Datentypen oder weniger
Datentypen als JSON? Gibt es da eigentlich
irgendwie haufenweise
Probleme, das immerher zu mappen?
Hast du schon mal was gehabt?
Also so viel hin und her mappen habe ich
jetzt nicht wirklich gemacht, wie das bei Serde gemacht ist,
dass die eine interne eigene
Datenrepräsentationsschicht haben.
Wenn du so einen Serializer oder die Serializer
schreibst, dann beschreibst du quasi
wie du hast deinen
Typen, was weiß ich, zum Beispiel
du hast deinen Typen, zum Beispiel
JSON-Objekt, dass diese
bestimmten Untertypen haben kann. Und das
interne Repräsentationsformat von Cerda
mappt eigentlich ziemlich genau auf das Rust-Typ-System.
Da hast du eine Auflistung, also du kannst
ein Array haben, du kannst ein Objekt
mit Keys haben, du kannst ein String haben, du kannst
Optional-Typen haben.
Und kannst Optional-Typen haben.
Und so weiter und so fort.
Und dementsprechend ist das
das gemeinsame, der gemeinsame
Teiler ist quasi das Rust-Typ-System.
Okay, spannend. Das heißt, was du mit dem
Rust-Typ-System ausdrücken kannst und da möchtest du
jetzt zum Schluss auch hin, kannst du dann auch
damit machen. Das heißt alles.
Das heißt, und weil das halt sehr expressive
ist, hast du da relativ wenig
Informationsverlust. Also
es kann sein, dass du, keine Ahnung,
wenn du irgendwelche Datenformate,
es fällt mir jetzt gerade nicht wirklich
was ein, wo du sagen könntest, hier kann ich was ausdrücken,
was ich damit nicht wirklich ausdrücken kann, das gibt's
bestimmt. Aber dann musst du halt
noch mehr Text und Informationen wahrscheinlich
ranschreiben und dann geht es trotzdem. Aber ja,
ich kann nicht was aus
YAML pausen und dann nach
verlustfrei nach JSON umwandeln.
Zum Beispiel, das geht nicht, weil
bei YAML
können Keys von Objekten
komplette Objekte sein.
Und es gibt so Sachen
wie Referenzen auf andere
Objekte. Also
nochmal, YAML ist ein
schönes Format, aber YAML kann zu viel.
Das ist was, was ich
an manchen Stellen schon verwendet habe.
Du kannst, wie gesagt, ein Objekt
haben und der Key von
Key-Value-Paaren ist ein weiteres
Objekt mit potenziell noch mehr
Schachtlung. Das ist durchaus möglich
in Java. Das ist super witzig. Und das kannst du
in JSON nicht ausdrücken.
JSON ist hier der Key.
Das Schöne an JSON ist,
dass es wirklich sehr klein ist
und es fehlen ein paar Sachen.
Das Schade an JSON
ist, dass es quasi mit seinem Namen lügt,
weil es nicht JavaScript ist.
Du kannst mit JavaScript-Objekten
mehr ausdrücken als mit JSON.
Aber es ist überschaubar.
Ja, es gibt ein paar Sachen, die wirklich fehlen.
Kommentare und Trading-Kommas und
Date-Values. Genau.
Ich finde es spannend, wenn du ein neues
TypeScript-Projekt anlegst, dann kriegst du eine
ts-config-json erzeugt
und die ist kein valides JSON.
Weil da nämlich Kommentare
drinstehen. Wenn ich die bei mir in Wim aufmache,
dann ist die Hälfte von der Datei rot,
weil mein
JSON-Highlighter in Wim Syntaxfehler
markiert und
Kommentare-Knie halten die gar nicht.
Sehr spannend.
Wenn ich eine Package-JSON-Kommentare
reinschreibe, beschwert sich NPM auch.
Das heißt, die müssen, um die
TS-Config-JSON zu parsen,
einen anderen Parser verwenden
als für die Package-JSON.
Schon komisch. Ich habe schon witzige Workarounds
gesehen, irgendwelche Objects,
Keys, die mit Comment anfangen
und dann lasse ich S-String einfach.
Ja, so machen wir das dann halt.
Das ist halt dumm.
Du kannst ja auch in JSON beliebige andere
Unterobjekte einfügen,
die halt keinen Sinn ergeben und dann sollten
halt syntaktisch korrekt sein.
Aber das kannst du dann halt als Kommentarverhältnis verwenden.
Warum nehmen wir nochmal JSON?
Ja, irgendjemand hat das mal irgendwo
benutzt, wo es jetzt häufig genommen wird
und dementsprechend... Es gibt ja auch
andere schöne Formate. Es gibt ja auch
AgeJSON.
Das war eigentlich dieser
ursprüngliche Ansatz, warum ich
dieses JSON-Orthethings
gebaut habe. Einfach irgendwas, was Serde nimmt und dann
von beliebigen Serialisierungsformaten in
andere beliebige Serialisierungsformate umwandelt.
weil ich einfach meine Package-JSON mit H-JSON schreiben wollte.
Und dann wollte ich irgendwas, was mir NPM rappt
und on the fly das umwandelt,
dass ich quasi einfach eine H-JSON hinlege und das immer aktuell ist.
Leider ist, es gibt einen H-JSON,
Serializer, Deserializer für Serda.
Der ist allerdings leider mit einer 0.8 oder 0.9 Version von Serda gebaut,
die absolut nicht kompatibel ist mit dem aktuellen Serda 1.0.
Ich dachte mir, ich nehme ja auch mal einen Tag und aktualisiere das mal,
aber das ist wirklich so trivial.
Und dementsprechend kannst du
leider nicht H.JSON
mit Serde parsen und dieses
Serde-repräsentative
Objekt dann mit einem anderen
aktuellen Serde
Serializer in ein anderes Format.
Du musst dann immer von denen die Version nehmen,
die auf der alten
Serde-Version basieren.
Das ist eigentlich auch so ein schönes Feature von Rust.
Die Version
Die Version deines Crates ist Teil deines
Typsystems.
Das beschwert sich zwar auf eine sehr
blöde Art und Weise, dass das nicht kompatibel
ist. Da steht dann,
Serda Value is not compatible with Serda Value.
Das könnten sie vielleicht noch in die Fehlermeldung einmelden,
dass Serda Value 0.8
nicht kompatibel ist mit Serda Value 1.0.
ich glaube, mir fällt gerade
eine Idee her. Ich habe gerade eine Idee für den RFC.
Nice.
Also spielt man mit Serda rum.
macht sehr viel Spaß. Das auf jeden Fall.
Cooles Teil.
Eine Sache, über die ich noch gestoppert bin. Ich habe ein witziges
Projekt entdeckt, das heißt Gitcoin.
Jetzt kann man natürlich wieder sagen, wieder neue
Cryptocurrency, Blockchain, Foo.
Ist es tatsächlich auch.
Ja, Git, also
um den Namen klar zu machen. Die wollen eine Plattform
schaffen. Also ich finde die Idee nobel.
Es ist zwar natürlich wieder fragwürdig,
was daraus wird und wie es sich entwickelt und
was es aktuell überhaupt sein will.
Aber die Idee dahinter ist,
dass du eine Plattform hast, wo
sagen wir mal quasi ein Reward
an GitHub-Issues dranhängst,
was das wert ist, wenn jemand dieses Feature
implementiert und dann kann jemand das für sich
claimen und das implementieren und
sobald es gemerged ist, kriegt er diesen
Geldwert in Ethereum, ist das glaube ich,
in Ether, dann zugeschrieben
über diese Plattform und kannst
dann damit quasi, also die wollen halt,
also das ist die noble Idee dahinter,
dass zumindest laut dem 30-sekündigen
Video auf deren Homepage,
dass du als Independent
Developer von deinem Lebensstil leben kannst
und nicht irgendwie in einer
großen Firma, wo du nur in Meetings bist und nicht das machen kannst,
was du eigentlich machen möchtest, nämlich
Software schreiben, dass du das tun kannst.
Ist zwar ein bisschen abstrus,
also das ist vielleicht ein bisschen sehr
weit gefasst, das Ganze,
aber ich finde es als Idee ganz spannend
und ich habe auch tatsächlich Interesse,
mich damit mal auseinanderzusetzen und mal zumindest
mal schauen, ob ich da irgendwas von den Sachen,
die da getaggt sind, als hier ist Geld
dran, mal was zu machen.
nicht der Erste, der glaube ich sowas in die Richtung macht, da gab es schon ähnliche
Anbieter vorher.
Signal hatte das mal in der iOS-App,
da habe ich mal gesehen, die hatten
irgendwie einen festen Betrag durch Sponsoren
bereitgestellt, der pro
Commit ausgezahlt wurde. Das ist natürlich auch eine komplett
komische Measure, das pro Commit zu machen,
aber du hast da irgendwie Geld bekommen pro Commit
an diesem Projekt und da gab es wohl auch schon
Möglichkeiten sowas vorher zu machen. Die machen das
jetzt über Ethereum, irgendwelchen
Smart Contract Krams
und fahren das auf. Es ist eine
witzige Idee. Ich bin auch willkommen, weil
die auch der Typ dahinter,
der das in dem gerufen hat, in der aktuellsten
Change-Hog-Folge, glaube ich, darüber spricht. Die habe ich noch nicht gehört.
Wäre vielleicht ein bisschen aufschlussreicher.
Die beschäftigen sich ja auch
in einigen Folgen damit, wie man
Open-Source-Sustainable machen kann.
Ja, ja. Das ist halt eine Idee, ein Ansatz.
Andere haben ja
manchmal habe ich
selten, aber manchmal habe ich auch Flatterlinks
in GitHub-Reports gesehen. Stimmt, kann man auch irgendwie mal.
Aber es gab doch noch so etwas anderes. Hieß das GitPay
oder so? Nee, es gibt aber auch andere
Dienste noch, die das gemacht haben. Es gab mal Gratapay,
die sind wohl seit kurzem Tod,
die früher Git-Tipp sogar noch davor hießen,
falls das jemand kennt.
Liberapay ist wohl aus Gratapay jetzt hervorgegangen
als Fork davon. Das ist so eine Art
Open-Source-Patreon, wenn ich mich richtig getroffen bin.
Schön, dass das Fork nennst du. Das ist wahrscheinlich eine
Firmenausgründung oder eine Neugründung oder so.
Also hier auf dem Blog steht
Bla, bla,
The Gratapocalypse resulting in Gratapay 2.0
and a fork Liberapay.
Also Liberapay ist ein Fork von Gratapay 2.
Und was genau GratterPay 2, jetzt will ich gleich
darauf eingehen, weiß ich nicht, müsste ich mich einlesen, aber
das geht wohl alles aus einer ähnlichen Idee und
Ideologie, ja Ideologie ist das
falsche Begriff, aus einer ähnlichen Idee hervor.
Ähnliche Motivation, genau.
Ich finde es schön, wie die Begriffe wie
Fork ist darüber, dass
kollaboratives Arbeiten
an Git-Repositories immer
Mainstreamer wird. Das ist das irgendwie
auch in den allgemeinen Sprachbebrauchungsgeschäften.
Ich möchte mal irgendwann von
irgendjemandem, der überhaupt keinen Code schreibt, den Begriff
Fork in so einem Zusammenhang hören.
Aber es gibt nochmal den Unterschied zwischen Hard Fork und GitHub Fork,
sagen manche Leute.
Der Hard Fork, sowas wie IOJS oder GitT aus Gox
und der GitHub Fork oder Soft Fork,
wie manche Leute tatsächlich online sagen,
der, hey, ich fork das mal, baue selber weiter
und schieb dir meine Änderungen zurück.
Der I smell a fork fork versus der Fork mir und GitHub Fork.
Sollten wir als Terminologie einführen, ja.
Nee, aber lieber Rapier müssen wir uns das auch mal anschauen.
Wir hatten ja auch schon mal überlegt,
ob wir irgendwie Flatter für unseren Podcast-Avent einrichten.
Haben es noch nicht geschafft.
Flatter ist mittlerweile auch irgendwie komplett neu gelauncht worden
und gibt es jetzt wieder.
Aber so richtig was Sauberes habe ich noch nicht gesehen.
Vielleicht ist ja lieber Repay so eine Variante für uns.
Ach, also ich bin auch ganz zufrieden damit,
wenn ihr unseren Podcast hört und uns mal irgendwo trefft,
wenn ihr uns mal ein Mato oder ein Bier ausgebt.
Oder nicht.
Ich will jetzt niemanden dazu verpflichten, uns was auszugeben.
Das ist ja noch viel schlimmer.
Was heißt denn hier verpflichten?
Wir müssen mal ein Hörertreffen machen.
Ja, finde ich cool.
Da gebe ich dann gerne auch eine Runde aus,
weil es kommen eh bloß drei Leute.
Wir und Steiger.
Den können wir auch mal wieder einladen
für die nächste Folge, ne?
Ja, finde ich cool.
Jo, wollen wir zu unseren GitHub-Stars der Woche kommen?
Klar, was hast du denn rausgesucht?
Rausgesucht nichts,
aber was an mir vorbeigescrollt ist
in meiner History war eine Sache.
Kennst du, hast du diesen
System Bus Radio Artikel gelesen?
Ich habe es gelesen, ja,
aber ich habe das Gefühl, ich bin noch nicht ganz dahinter
gestiegen, was von der Basis das eigentlich läuft.
Also ich glaube, richtig verstehen
werde ich es auch nicht, aber die
Quintessenz von diesem Projekt ist, also hier gibt es
ein Gitterprojekt, wo das
Referenzier implementiert ist
und dir sagt der Begriff, er gibt was, oder?
Ja. Also dein Computer ist
geergebt, wenn er wirklich
rundum von Luft umgeben ist
und kein Signalweg
rein oder raus führt, quasi ein Gerät, wo du
wirklich physisch davor sitzen musst, was nicht
als Internet angeschlossen ist.
Wi-Fi ist so eine Sache.
Das ist so ein Sicherheitskonzept.
Da ist das wichtige Zeugs drauf.
Unsere Server sind in verplombten Schränken.
Der Begriff ist
älter als Wireless.
Aber es gibt unterschiedliche Angriffe auf geergäbte Systeme.
Es gab
vor ein paar Jahren ein Projekt,
das hat über Ultraschall gefunkt
und hat dann, wenn du die Software einmal
über USB oder einen anderen Angriff
auf deinem
Windows-System installiert hast, hat es über
Ultraschall dann Signale rausgesendet
und empfangen und gelauscht. Das ist
mäßig erfolgreich gewesen
und das hier, dieses System
Bus Radio ist auch nochmal spannend.
Es gibt bestimmte Hardware-Instruktionen
in deiner CPU, zum Beispiel
irgendwelche Operationen auf
Bit-Integer-Zahlen,
die für so ein bisschen
Radiostrahlung sorgen.
Und hier gibt es ein Projekt, das dann
mit wirklich gutem Timing
einen Code schreibt,
der einfach in bestimmten Frequenzen
diese Operation ausführt
und dadurch deine CPU
zu einem Radiosender macht.
Und auf die Art und Weise kannst du aus
einem System rausstrahlen,
was vorher kein Radio hatte.
Also hier wird beschrieben,
du kannst dann auf der Frequenz
1580 Kilohertz
kannst du dann
Sachen damit empfangen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das noch mit einem Radiosender
empfangbar ist, aber die Leute,
die sich mehr mit
tatsächlichen CPU-Architekturen auskennen,
als ich, schaut euch diesmal an.
Es ist ein ziemlich krasser Tobak hier,
was hier gezeigt wurde. Also es ist vorführbar
auf einem 2015er
MacBook Air.
Und
was von der Distanz
habe ich...
Also auf jeden Fall nicht nur Zentimeter oder so.
Es ist auf jeden Fall was,
oder wenn du ein befallenes System
hast, was geergebt ist,
vielleicht ein bisschen was rauskriegst, wenn du
nebenan stehst und einen richtigen Empfänger hast.
Aber es ist schon ein witziger Proof of
Concept. Auf jeden Fall. Es ist unglaublich krass,
dass sowas geht. Und es ist halt,
wie gesagt, du musst wirklich auf das Timing
aufpassen, dass du auch sinnvolle Signale checkst.
Aber Leute, die sich mit zum Beispiel Software
Defined Radio auseinandergesetzt haben,
die wissen schon relativ gut,
wie sowas geht. Dementsprechend ist das, glaube ich, durchaus
möglich. Ja.
Können wir auch mal jemanden finden, der
Nachrichtentechnik-Kram macht.
Finde ich cool. So, cool.
Einmal, was ich mir rausgesucht habe, ist ein in Haskell geschriebenes Projekt namens Buchhaltung. Das ist ein Command-Line-Tool, soweit ich das verstanden habe. Ich habe es leider noch nicht ausprobiert, wollte ich noch machen.
Achso, das ist tatsächlich Code. Ich dachte, da schmeißt einfach jemand irgendwelche Dokumente auf.
Nee, nee, das ist tatsächlich Code, der sich zur Aufgabe gemacht hat, dass er über FinTS oder HBCI oder ich glaube dieses OFX-Format, was ja auch so ein Datenformat ist, mit dem du Daten aus Banken rausbekommst oder deine Transaktionsdaten aus Banken aus einem Konten rausbekommst oder aus Online-Backing-Software oder was auch immer.
oder aus anderen, direkt aus PayPal oder diversen Visa-Karten exportierten Daten,
die das einliest, dieses Tool-Lamits-Buchhaltung und in ein standardisiertes Format bringt,
was andere Tools aus diesem Ledger-Projekt lesen können.
Das ist ein sehr bekanntes Projekt und das ist einfach erlaubt,
all dein Kram, dein Finanzkram, also wie gesagt, Transaktionen auf deinen Konten
und was auch immer, Aktivitäten, darauf zu agieren und zu archivieren
und das alles schön lesbar zu halten.
Und das ist recht cool, dieses Buchhaltung.
Ich fand es vor allem cool, weil es halt, ich mag es auch,
weil die in Heske geschrieben ist, das ist hart,
was da habe ich was für über, obwohl ich selber
nicht sehr viel damit anfangen kann.
Nur halt grundlegende Dinge,
hat für mich das immer so ein gewisses Merkmal, da steckt Liebe drin.
Das ist von jemandem, der da ein bisschen Zeit
und Liebe reingesteckt hat. Da gab es wohl mal einen Leidensdruck.
Genau.
Und das hat hier ein paar
coole Features, um darauf
zu agieren, auf diesen Daten, kommt auch
mit mehreren Personen klar, also wenn du
für deinen Partner mit Dinge managen möchtest und so weiter.
Ich persönlich
habe das jetzt vom Matmal,
das Ledger-Kram ein bisschen rumgespielt gehabt,
habe meine Sachen aber alle in You Need a Budget
drin aktuell und versuche die trotzdem
bei mir auch lokal immer zu archivieren, einfach
als CSV-Dump, damit mir die Daten
nicht verloren gehen, weil wenn ich mal
meine Online-Banking-Daten verliere, meine Bank
hat die halt auch nicht mehr von vor
ein paar Jahren. Du kannst vor allem, wenn du das
exportierst oder
kannst du nur bis zu 90 Tage
oder drei Monate zurück,
kannst du ja bloß bis zu 90 Tage
rückwirkend dein Zeugs runterladen.
Eben, meine Bank hält das eben
nicht mehr vor. Deswegen halte ich persönlich meine Daten
seit 2012 von all meinen Konten
und habe die eben lokal archiviert
und ich möchte da einfach manchmal ein bisschen
schauen, wie viel habe ich denn bei sowas schon ausgegeben.
Das ist jetzt simple Queries oder vielleicht mal
irgendwie drauf, keine Ahnung, drauf trainieren
auf die Daten, wer weiß, wenn mir das nicht,
was in den Use Case einfällt.
Ah, ich habe für sowas eine Zeit lang
KMyMoney verwendet.
Das hat noch schon...
Das benutzt AQ-Banking.
Dieses ist hier auch als
Prerequisites aufgezählt.
Und dieses Buchhaltung,
verwendet das die Sachen oder
implementiert das das Neue?
Soweit ich das verstanden habe,
es implementiert natürlich jetzt nicht irgendwelche...
Also, ich meine,
Doc geht jetzt nicht an irgendwelche spezifischen Tools
an, sondern nutzt die gleichen Formate
und stelle das eben in derselben Form zurecht,
dass du damit weiterarbeiten kannst.
Also zumindest, ich habe eine Zeit lang dafür
K-My-Money verwendet, einfach um die Sachen runterladen
zu können, aber im Endeffekt ist das eine riesige
GUI-Anwendung, die super gruselig ist
und auch häufig
veraltet, aber ich mag das, wenn ich
meine
Einträge auf meinem Kontoauszug
irgendwie kategorisieren kann und dann
sortieren kann, dass so viel habe ich für Musik, so viel
habe ich für Essen, so viel habe ich für Sport
oder was weiß ich ausgegeben.
Aber dadurch, dass das
derartig
friedlich ist, das irgendwie mit einer GUI zu machen,
hatte ich schon mal länger überlegt, ob ich das
einfach mit einem Kommandozeilen-Tour mache, dass ich zumindest
in der CSV, in der standardisierten
CSV dumpen kann und dann vielleicht hinterher
irgendwann mal mit, keine Ahnung,
was weiß ich, mit irgendeinem Excel oder sowas
dann was draus zu visualisieren.
Man nutzt ja eh einen Mac.
Einfach, was ich sehr gerne nutze, um an
Online-Banking-Dienste anzudocken, ist MoneyMoney.
Das ist eine GUI-App für Mac, die ist
nicht sonderlich dick, die ist sehr, sehr kompakt
sieht schick aus und
funktioniert großartig und das Coole ist, habe ich erst vor ein paar Tagen
gemerkt, das Ding hat, also das habe ich
vor einer kleinen Weile gemerkt,
das hat Support für Plugins oder Extensions,
wie sie sagen, und habe mir
vor ein paar Tagen eine Extension geschrieben für
Money Money, dass ich
in Lua witzigerweise, sind die Extensions
geschrieben, wie klassische Skriptsprachdinge
halt, habe in meinem Leben noch nicht so viel
Lua geschrieben, das sind 100 Zeilen Lua, um
Daten vom Studentenwerk Dresden,
Transaktion auf meiner E-Mail-Karte, also der Karte,
mit dem wir die Mensen hier zahlen, runterzuladen.
Die haben dieses Kartenservice-Portal,
haben sogar eine JSON-API und du kannst die Daten runterladen
und sehen, was du in welcher Mensa
wann gekauft hast, für wie viel Geld.
Finde ich sehr witzig, dass da jetzt ein Online-Banking-Tool mit drin
und sammelt die Daten.
Lua ist eine komische Sprache.
Ja, es soll halt gut embeddable sein.
Das ist das eine Feature von Lua.
Aber ich habe damit auch nur
wenig Erfahrung.
Ja, aber gucken wir mal.
Obwohl, sprich mal anders an.
Ich glaube, ich bin sogar geeignet.
Was hast du noch?
Eine Kleinigkeit, die ich noch habe,
da habe ich mal ganz kurz rumgespielt, ist Amp.
Das ist ein neuer Kommandozeilen-basierter
Editor, der jetzt ein bisschen
den kleinen Starburst hatte
gestern auf GitHub.
Ich habe ihn mal bei mir gebaut,
ging relativ einfach und dann mal ausprobiert.
Auf der Webseite steht, dass er von
Wim so ein bisschen
inspiriert sein soll.
Und dementsprechend habe ich sofort
Probleme gehabt, das Ding wieder zu beenden,
wo ich nicht genau wie ich rauskomme, weil
er nicht auf
Doppelpunkt Q
reagiert hat.
Er unterstützt Wim-Motions,
du kannst mit J und K hin und her gehen,
aber
einen
Kommando-Modus wie in Wim gibt's nicht.
Achso.
Man beendet ihn also mit
STRG-C.
Das killt den Editor direkt?
Ja, das ist irgendwie so.
So schön fand ich es nicht.
aber Sonntagshileiting
für diverse Sprachen und
eigentlich ein schönes Teil.
So ein Werftprojekt, oder?
Ich glaube ja, deswegen ist das so in meiner
Filterbubberung drin gewesen.
Du hast noch eins.
Als letztes Projekt habe ich mir heute noch zurechtgelegt,
das ist wieder vom Helge, von dem ich letztes Mal schon was gepickt habe.
Hi Helge.
Ein Projekt namens Mikroexpress,
der hat einfach mal auf der Swift Server API,
das ist dieses von den
Swift Server, der Swift Server Gruppe
Leuten zurecht,
gelegte Library, die quasi
den Low-Level-HTTP-Kram komplett
handeln soll und die Basis für jegliches
Server-Framework sein soll, hat er
aufgesetzt und ein Projekt
namens Microexpress gebaut, was quasi eine
Minimal-Implementation von dem,
was man, oder die API, die man kennt
von Node-Express sein soll
als Web-Server. Und das Ganze
ist einfach mal in knapp 200 Zeilen
geschrieben und sieht tatsächlich aus wie Express
und es ist irgendein typisches Routing,
was du dann draufsetzen kannst.
Du hast Middleware, Middleware ist halt
als eine Funktion mit Inputs und Outputs.
Das ist in dem Fall einfach eine Closure, die du randockst.
Aber das finde ich recht schick. Und der hat dazu auch noch
einen Blogpost geschrieben, wo er genau drauf eingeht,
wie, also durchgesprochen,
was braucht man denn?
Und jetzt schreiben wir diese, das hier.
Und dann, ach so, klar, jetzt läuft das natürlich noch nicht,
wenn man das direkt hier von woanders
in diesem To-Do-MVC als Beispiel, das ich backnehme.
Klar, Core-Bauwärtschnellreihen ist auch nur fünf Zeilen.
Und das finde ich schön sauber erklärt,
was braucht man eigentlich alles on top?
Wie schauen die Request-Objekte, wie schauen die Spawns-Objekte aus?
Auf was muss man da eben achten?
Das ist ein recht schickes, winziges Projekt,
um das zu machen. Das finde ich ein sehr angenehmer
Start, um mal da ein bisschen tiefer
einzusteigen. Wie schaut so ein
Web-Framework eigentlich aus? Was muss das eigentlich alles können?
Und tatsächlich ist das eigentlich gar nicht mal so viel.
Natürlich kann man da noch diverse Ebenen drauflegen,
aber das ist echt schon mal schön gekapselt.
Gefällt mir. Irgendwie könnte man dem auch so
einen Namen geben. Ist das Express-esk?
So eine API,
ich definiere mir eine App und dann
habe ich so Bilder-Pattern-mäßige
Methoden, wo ich reinschreibe Get und dann
einen String auf dem es oder einen Path auf dem es
reagieren soll und dann hänge ich da mit Closures
dort ein. Das ist eigentlich was, was man in
vielen Frameworks sieht. Ja, klar.
Sinatra sieht jetzt auch nicht grob anders aus als das.
Alle kleinen Web-Frameworks ähneln sich,
dass du irgendwo simple routes definierst,
dann ein Request-Aberget reinbekommst
und irgendwie eine Response rauskippst und
am Ende irgendeinen Port oder eine URL zum
Listenern, IP
und einen Port zum Listenern freigibst.
Also was mich bei diesen
Express-esken APIs
an vielen Stellen doch so ein bisschen stört
ist, dass es, oder was heißt, stört ist,
mir erst aufgefallen, als ich dann andere APIs gesehen habe,
ist, dass sie halt doch
stringly typed sind.
Kann man da, also ich meine, irgendwo
müssen die String sehr rumliegen, wie willst du das anders machen?
Beziehungsweise nicht wohl strukturiert
oder beziehungsweise
dynamisch getypt. Also du hast
immer so eine API, du hängst dann zwar
mit einem String einfach deine
Route ein, deine Route ist dann
was weiß ich, slash mu oder slash
dason und dann empfängst
du irgendein Request-Objekt und was du dann
reinbekommst, das musst du
dann selber parsen. Entweder weil du weißt, dass du
JSON bekommst oder weil du weißt, dass du irgendwas
anderes bekommst. Ach so, in die Richtung meinst du, dass du
klar getypt einfach sagen kannst, hier...
Deine Typen sind quasi das, was HTTP auch
bloß kennt, nämlich Strings.
Und du weißt, dass du ein Body hast
und du weißt, dass du Sachen als Query
reinkriegst, aber der Query muss ja
auch noch nicht unbedingt geparset sein. Der Query ist auch bloß
ein String, den du reinkriegst, den du noch selber
parsen musst. Und da treten dann Sachen auf.
Das sind Sachen, die...
Das ist so bei vielen von diesen
Frameworks. Das sind
Sachen, die werden ja automatisch weggeräppt von
so großen Frameworks wie Rails.
Aber das ist das, was ich zum Beispiel an Rocket ganz schön
finde, diesem Ding in Rust.
Wo du, da
beschreibst du deine Route, indem
du eine Methode schreibst, die
bestimmte Typen annimmt.
Und dann kannst du,
dann wird der Code
generiert, der das
statisch prüft, ob die Sachen, die du reinbekommst,
auch wirklich diesem Interface entsprechen.
Und wenn du jetzt irgendwo als
Parameter in einem Query eine Zahl erwartest
und aber keine kriegst,
dann kriegst du wirklich von dem Ding einen Fehler.
Dann matcht die Route halt nicht.
Du musst nicht selber die Fehlerbehandlung
jeden Fall abfangen.
Das geht halt nur für bestimmte...
Ich dachte jetzt, das geht noch einen Schritt weiter.
Das betrifft natürlich die URL-Parameter,
die ja entweder Strings oder Zahlen sind quasi.
Ob Double oder Int,
das geht, glaube ich, alles drei prinzipiell.
Aber mehr kannst du auch nicht in eine URL packen
als diese drei Sachen.
Aber zum Beispiel Dinge, die du in Body mit schickst,
als JSON kodiert, die könntest du auch direkt mit typisieren
und sagen, du hast ja eine Route, die geht auf JSON
und die erwartet einen Person-Type.
Und dann muss dieser Person-Type halt auch so mit
in dem Request-Body drinstecken, sonst matcht die Route halt nicht.
Das könntest du halt machen, das sehe ich nicht, was dagegen spricht.
Das wäre auch sehr cool.
Genau. Also sowas ist, ich meine, es gibt auch andere Frameworks
aus anderen Sprachen.
Wenn du dann wirklich was Größeres skalieren,
des Bauinvils, dann
brauchst du ja schon...
Jetzt wiederhole ich mich.
Aber ja,
Micro Express
sieht schon ziemlich schick aus.
Ich würde mir am liebsten mal den Code im Hintergrund
dazu durchlesen.
Was hast du?
Das ist Swift-Service-Sache oder was?
Ja, schau dir mal an, die ist auch recht schick.
Es gibt natürlich direkt ein To-Do-Model.
Sehr schön.
Achso, jetzt Micro Express.
Micro Express ist halt wirklich...
Das ist halt nicht viel Code, das ist echt überschaubar.
sehr schön, klein.
Also ich meine, es gibt direkt ein
ein
kleines
To-Do
MVC, nee, gotcha, es gibt
direkt eine kleine To-Do-Anwendung.
Die globale Variable, die globale Array-To-Dos
This is our database.
Since it is immutable, it is very, very fast.
If not useless.
Pretty chic.
Es sind auch bloß drei
To-Do-Items drin. Der eine erste hat
ID 42, bei Beer, der zweite hat
1337, buy more beer.
Nächstes 88.
ID 88.
Drink beer. Die ist ja als einzige
completed.
Okay, cool.
Also yet another Express Implementation.
Ja, aber es ist ein schönes Beispiel,
was man minimal auf die Swift HTTP
Library drauflegen kann, um schon was
sehr anschauliches, Funktionales zu haben.
Wir haben hier noch
Errata und Nachträger zur letzten Sendung. Wir hatten ja erzählt,
dass man
auf denen Meltdown und Spectre gepatcht wurde,
regelrecht sieht.
Und wir haben hier einen schönen von dem AppOptics-Blog
eine schöne Visualisierung der Auswirkungen von Meltdown auf AWS.
Und dann sieht man wirklich,
wie da Average CPU Utilization
im ganzes Stück nach oben geht,
beziehungsweise Average Capacity
ein ganzes Stück runter geht an manchen Stellen.
Ein schöner Blogpost, wo das auch nochmal
zusammengefasst wurde. Man sieht eine ganze Menge
entweder
scharf ansteigende oder scharf
abfallende Kurven, was
schon ein bisschen kritisch aussieht.
Die Auswirkungen visualisiert
und man sieht, dass da tatsächlich der Patch
recht krasse Effekte hat.
Es sind natürlich, das ist
wie jetzt mal ein Beipackzettel von irgendeinem
Medikament liest, da sind jetzt nur die krassesten
Beispiele. Na klar. Wenn du
eine sehr rechenintensive Anwendung hast,
dann hast du nicht so eine große Auswirkung,
wie wenn du eine sehr IO-intensive Anwendung hast.
Aber gerade wenn du
Virtualisierungsdienstleister bist
und viel zwischen unterschiedlichen
VMS hin und herspringst, das sind so Kontext-Switches,
die dann jetzt teurer werden auf die Art und Weise.
Wenn du
Bitcoins meinst, wirst du nicht so gut sagen.
Bitcoin ist tot.
Ist es tot? Fast.
Fast? Ich habe immer noch 8 Euro
in Bitcoin auf meinem Handy, aber ich
kriege die, glaube ich, immer noch nicht runter, weil die
Transaktionsgebühr immer noch höher ist als
das, was ich da drauf habe.
Was ist denn die nächste Crypto-Coin?
Banana-Coin.
Das habe ich gelesen.
Ist das wirklich wahr?
Ja, es existiert, aber
ich meine das jetzt
nicht ernst. Also die Leute meinen das wahrscheinlich
schon recht ernst, die ein Banana-Coin
bauen. Banana-Coin.io.
Ich glaube, das lassen wir jetzt alles raus.
Ja.
Wrappen wir die Sendung, glaube ich, an dieser Stelle ab.
Das war akronomisierbar.
Folge 14. Vielen Dank, dass
ihr den neuen Feed abonniert habt.
Ob ihr wolltet oder nicht. Euer Kleid hat es für euch
einfach getan. Vielen Dank, dass ihr uns
keine bösen Nachrichten schreibt, warum wir unseren
Feed umziehen.
Und ansonsten hören wir uns
bei Folge 15 in vielleicht
zwei Wochen wieder. Mal schauen, ich will nichts
versprechen. Danke auf jeden Fall fürs Zuhören.
Die nächste Folge in eurem Podcatcher beginnt
in 3, 2,
1.